you got caught on the beach somewhere in
New York on your finger Lamborghini lmo2
Lima doing like winning on the beach and
you know that's hard to do want to say
that you know that Lambo cars I never
drove everybody welcome to another
episode of hot boxing I'm Evan Britain
and I'm Mike Tyson man Mike we got a
great job bringing back memories Stewie
Manny the professional historian on the
car tips - oh yes he is Ben baller
welcome of that name right man and you
know what's funny is when I heard the
name I thought that it was about like
you're a baller with money and [ __ ] but
I mentally cuz you're a baller yeah on
the field playing football and
basketball yeah I was the first Asian in
my university ever do boot do both
I didn't play a lot but I got my PT and
when I did I you know I was I was a I
felt like I was a late learner with
learning plays but my coach was like
y'all you're uncoachable but you got a
lot of talent and you just don't have
the genetic you know build to do what
you do but you know we'll get into that
man yeah I thought those dope as hell
though man Thank You Man thank you so um
I love the young kid I probably 21 so I
moved to this place called Bernards in
New Jersey and Bernards in New Jersey is
a very um the people that lived it like
'man and the Mars family and stuff like
that the Englehart family the people
that they big well yeah people that
double-oh-seven called Vanderbilt's IP
the Diamond Jim Brady knows it so one
day I'm just moved in the neighborhood
Bernards there right and the hole comes
visit me I'm Malcolm Forbes all right
and nobody's driving a green lmo2
that would give me truck I said what is
that
what is that I found my hard to get
where I got one man I there's a couple
around but a lot of people that
obviously like that what you know don't
make the part for no more yeah not just
that they made them they made so few
back then and there were some issues
with the from back then
oh the motor here they have issues all
the people who do have them these are
guys who have you know hundred million
dollar car collections well yeah you was
in a deep so I mean you're the go-to guy
for the jewels for the time I know
nothing about you when this came it was
some other guy this Algerian guys
massacre that was the guy for one moment
I'm right here I'm giving the he came oh
you know what actually uh he came after
name was Chris Ayer yeah Chris Ayers a
African dude he's uh you know what tell
you the truth man he was a little bit of
inspiration to me as well when I was
coming up cuz I my professional career
out the gate was music and DJing so I
was a nightclub DJ and was going out the
second time I ever saw you in public was
at the Roxbury nightclub the legendary
Roxbury on Sunset and I remember walking
in there and I shouldn't have been in
there cuz I was I was too young I was
doing college and I saw some ester
Stallone I saw like just like these are
like come on now you see like a youtube
star like oh my god has 10 million
fathers oh come on man this is rocky bro
this is like [ __ ] Tyson and here's
Magic Johnson it was it was crazy in
there right you know I was in love with
hip-hop and and since there since 80s
and so ice-t is kind of like my
unofficial Godfather he kind of took me
in I met him in 82 and I was
breakdancing then at this club in LA and
Mike Tyson was showing a movie called
break in there so you know for a long
time I was in hip-hop and then elevated
into the professional side of the career
and then after that I just got so sick
of music and it wasn't about I I hated
music I got sick of the music business
and it was very similar to any sport
where you got managers and lawyers in it
and agents and people all in your
pockets and all kinds of [ __ ] and I was
like yo man this is some real
[ __ ] cuz a lot of these people don't
know how to read a contract and even if
they have an attorney that it it's like
five attorneys that run three hundred
thousand different rappers you know I
mean our singers and it's like Yoda
students know what the [ __ ] he's was
don't worry about it you know I'm saying
it's like listen half my family is
Jewish and whatever but like you got the
Jewish attorneys who are like like [ __ ]
it don't worry about it it's okay
you know they have a chance to go over
it and if there's something they don't
understand boom but some of these kids
had no other option so they want to get
on so you tell me this what are we gonna
do about that
that rate D would you talking about
where this industry is ran by a certain
amount of people they really don't give
a [ __ ] because nowhere else you didn't
go but us I mean we have to somehow
campaign to push these young brothers
that listen school wasn't for me if I
didn't get asked out I was the only
person on my school that didn't
academically excel my brother went to
school with the Kennedys we came from a
poor family my brother went to Phillips
Academy
you know school and over you know my
sister's Exeter like you're talking
about there with school with the
Kennedys these people that was off
education because my dad whooped our
asses like we could never beat our kids
asses the way my god I know I'm
experience a little older than you
thought no one is like if you from a
poor family don't know is to beat you
into some yeah so you know now with
these kids they just they don't want to
they don't want to they don't want to
marinate they don't want to season the
meat they want to just eat that fast
food and go they want to get their
contract they want to get [ __ ] but the
people who are smart and let it let it
sit a little bit set it stirring the pot
a little bit they're getting the right
attorneys again the right advice or
they're going independent taking more of
their masters only more of their own
thing and what I was getting at when
you're talking about Chris hair and
stuff it's unfortunate because you know
I came in a game with no like real like
you know most of most of the jewelry
people it's like it's like you got
people in Africa who run the trade and
you know it's it's predominantly white
but it's like there's not a lot of
jewelers that we're doing what I was
doing when I won jeweler of the year two
years ago this is like there's millions
of jewelers in the world you know what I
mean
from high/low people who you know are
handling billions of dollars of diamonds
and I'd like to say you know just
because I grew up in the hood all my
life being a person of color you know I
was proud to accept that award but I
went out there and wore this nice dior
suit and I say
to put me in and a lady's like yo what
are you doing and I was [ __ ] me with
my doing $6,000 suit you know I'm about
to fall out you know even she goes no go
back upstairs and wear your street
clothes put on your supreme puttin a
[ __ ] and show your tattoos like with me
because you opened up an entire
unorthodox way of being a jeweler we're
not wearing a polo not wearing a
button-down that one and going out there
wearing tattoos and talking the way you
do on your social media like that's me
that's just I don't want to not be me
because every time I haven't I've
regretted it so with Chris Eyre I don't
know where he is now but I'm like you
know people will sit there and hate and
talk [ __ ] they don't know about my
background be like you know how come
there's not more black jewelers out
there and I'm like because that you know
there's there's people [ __ ] hating on
their parcels parcel is like how you buy
diamonds and stuff right and it be like
you know they might see like Oh Jamal
Johnson and just immediately stereotype
oh this guy's by who is this guy you
know do we know this guy oh oh you know
what we ran out we don't have any it's
just like on some [ __ ] it's every
business has it but like with attorneys
and everything I mean there just needs
to be more people of color in charge who
are more fair people in Moore there's no
black jewellers I could think of I can't
think of one do you know out there so
it's like you know um that just has to
be it's and it's not even like it is
education but it's more information I
feel like we just need to information is
great nothing more important information
right information information is only
good once you brought into the brought
into the subject once you brought into
the club then the informations good yeah
once you're now he needs a mentor
somebody I'm sorry that's what it is
mighty black in this community they
wants to be in the diamond business
needs a mentor I don't know if these
Jewish white whoever's in that business
right hey this isn't fair we're getting
all these [ __ ] diamonds from Africa
it's not a black [ __ ] I asked
him I forgot I owned any part of this so
we need to make something happen and
because of that and and and shout out to
my boy Frank Brown who works here rise
like Frank lived in Israel for a while
yeah and a lot of my dimes came from
Israel India I tried to avoid Africa
ship because you know you see what's
going on over there and you like you
know man the parts of this right but let
me backtrack now to the attorney side
and I know this doesn't really matter
but like my business managers Africa
African he's black he's a he's a brother
he's you know he's a Muslim and he's oh
gee his dad used to run with Public
Enemy in them and I [ __ ] with him heavy
because he has such a dope list of
clients and sometimes people be like you
know you don't have like Goldberg or
Steinberg or you know or this person
holding your money I'm like nah bro what
you mean and I'm the richest I've ever
been in my entire life [ __ ] like
I'm paper yeah I got I got everything I
need and yeah in fact this dude saved my
life I owe the IRS paper you know I mean
and he came in and say I mean I was like
yo I didn't give a [ __ ] what color the
person was personally tell the truth I
really don't in life with anything
whether it be friendship business or
anything
there's stereotypes yes but who's best
for the job that's what I want to know
obscene and I mean that's just how I
grew up because I grew up in a
predominantly Latin in black
neighborhood and now it's gentrified
into you know Koreans and whatever but
you you just have to have to have to
mentor somebody and I feel like that's
another thing I've been toward people
I've been speaking at schools and stuff
and like people are like oh you're just
a jeweler and I'm like Jesus Christ cuz
there's so much miss you know like lost
information between these generations
they don't know like you know that I was
in music they don't know that I was you
know in in sports they don't know that I
was the I have a lot of information I
know a lot of things you know but I need
to I need I need I need to do more work
and you know my store was in the hood
for a long time it was one block away
from Nipsey Hussle store sometimes we
need people to open the door for us ya
know for sure you know any people open
the door absolutely because a lot of us
because sometimes about stereotype that
we had we become so stereotyped we start
to stereotype ourselves in life and say
we can't do that because of who we are
where we farm away
we've been associated with and then
sometimes then and when that happened
you get somebody that's you say he's in
the world he's connected and he tells
everybody this person always saying I
can't do this because I'm that these
tells everybody disguise when with this
guys with us now he's one of us yeah
like a mafia and your whole [ __ ] life
change they don't even see your color no
more your whole [ __ ] life change it's
true though
you know um when I got into the music
business my best friend's dad
is a very very very very powerful person
Hollywood mostly in music but he
produced a Rocky Horror Picture Show
started that he did all the Cheech and
Chong movies he's a big activism I wanna
early he owns the Roxy a lot of
nightclubs he produced the Mamas and the
Papas Carole King he produced some of
the biggest albums in the history of
rock he had a festival before Woodstock
called the Monterey Pop Festival names
Lou Adler and he took me in became a
godfather and Lou Adler took me in when
I got my first job I Priority Records
I met dr. Dre and Suga and all these
guys at a nightclub I was DJing at that
Denzel Washington owned and that was
where I met everybody and I remember one
night dr. Dre walked in and it was like
a night where the boss was like amen
none of that n-word music you know I
mean I was like I was like come on man
no I need to place with my [ __ ] rock
if you wanna play some some Al Jarreau
if you want to play a little Michael
Jackson cool but I don't wanna know you
know no gangster [ __ ] and I was like
[ __ ] man and he left and I heard he was
going to Oscar De La Hoya fight so he's
gonna Vegas on the jet so I said man
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
I saw Dre sitting down and I said listen
man there's a bunch of TV's place was
called Creek Ali's Jamaican restaurant
Melrose they used to own Georgia which
is a block away to Georgia was amazing
[ __ ] so yeah Georgia was a beautiful
so same George I remember George George
was Debbie Allen
that can Debbie Allen Brad Johnson brand
John from New York
yes Oh Brad Debbie Allen bud yes so so
Norman and Brad on this piece too so
they all took off and I said [ __ ]
because the crowd was mostly black you
know I mean I was like manager man
restaurant [ __ ] they said we're open
till 2:00 in the morning you get poppin
right so I turned off the [ __ ] I turn I
said listen I told everyone there my boy
was like he's like Amen all right that's
on you guys let it be on me then I put
the Mack on one screen
I'll put super flour on the other screen
I put [ __ ] cofee on another one and
then I said listen I started out with
some funk James Brown you know some Roy
Ayers some jazz and then I got into like
then I got into some [ __ ] and I remember
dr. Dre I walked downstairs he's have a
never forget he had a Long Island iced
tea and hey youngster what you know
about all that up there and I was like
man I just grew up listening to Earth
Wind & Fire you know music was always my
[ __ ]
parliament-funkadelic George clean he
was like yo man let me get your you got
a number I guess I could get my pager
number you know get my pager number a
week later he hit me up I'm in death row
studios you know we're getting together
boom he's kind of about to make a move
leaving death row so he put me with his
og label priority and when I got there I
was like man let me figure this out and
I got a lot of people hating on me and
meanwhile you got all these people in
black music but you have all the
lower-level people that other people of
color all the executives or the white
folks right and I don't mean to say
anything cuz like white people here but
you know they're like white people yeah
they're like you know what just what's
this Chinese [ __ ] know about
hip-hop first of all I'm Korean
second of all like I've been around the
[ __ ] all my life you know I mean it's a
it's in my heartbeat so you know get
that [ __ ] out the way first because I
was always that dude I was in there we
go back and forth and um within two
years I became vice president the
company you know we have Master P I
signed with signed jay-z you know we had
Ice Cube we had a lot of heavy hitters
coming out of there and I have to thank
you know um drain these guys because it
was a black dude and and you know and
and and of course Lou Adler and them
they got me this chance to get in there
but when it came to handling my contract
my employment contract when I was
actually gonna get a six-figure contract
which was a lot then for a you know for
work I had to hit up Louie at live like
yo who do I get and he's like yo man you
gonna work with just do a Peter Paterno
who's actually dr. Dre still attorney
and Peter Paterno is a huge he's like
the Bob Shapiro Johnnie Cochran of
entertainment lawyers and I was like all
right cool then I realized how different
things were and then I was like yo man
this is [ __ ] crazy because I was
about to sign this dude I don't want to
say his name but he was artist I was on
a label that was in a group with Ice
Cube and then he came for a solo record
and my boss was like yo man just do this
dope let's pick him up real quick
let's give him a hundred grand you know
I'm saying let's get him some Versace
shirts that's gonna hook tup one
whatever's take much to a nice dinner
let's get him to sign his car show this
do it let's do a quick deal and I looked
over the deal quick quickly and I was
like yo man this dude's [ __ ] [ __ ]
about the zionists [ __ ] life away
like I mean back then it wasn't like now
now you can make six albums in four
years I know it sounds corny I mean
Tupac was writing [ __ ] 100 albums in
one year but I mean back then
studio time was so expensive you didn't
have the resources whatever six albums
might take you 10 years 15 year you
about to sign your entire life away and
not know it
and he was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] man I'm
about to get on bro yeah I'm about to
get rich I'm about to boom and just
doesn't know any signs of contract I'm
just like you know so now so you saw him
I saw behind the scenes dynasty's now
now me being an entrepreneur being an
owner you know I make everyone's jewelry
you know I'm saying I'm a Michael
Jackson Julie I don't give a [ __ ] you
know whatever the allegations here and
there I mean I'm 5050 I don't know
Michael Jackson's the baddest
[ __ ] ever did it whatever you
say whatever you Evvie what it is but
what he did he became the baddest
[ __ ] to ever did it on this
planet for sure I said yeah all right
that's all so none of us are perfect on
this planet no not at all and that's one
of the reasons why I allows you so much
and before you walked in there what did
I tell you I said listen in high school
my senior year I got a scholarship to
play football and asked me said to be
named three of your idols and I said
number one Bruce Lee forgot forever
Bruce Lee you know Nemean bruce lee is
my idol forever and number two was Bob
Marley just because I just I [ __ ] with
Bob so heavy and anything else I said
number three was Mike Tyson and they
looked at me like Mike Tyson you know
that means a bad boy I'm like yeah man
but you know what I've been kicked out
of ten schools and look I'm getting a
second chance a third chance for that
school to him yeah so you know I was
like yeah of course Mike Tyson but you
know going on one of my things is and I
made Joey for every single rapper you
could think of I'm still doing [ __ ] with
and I'm doing bigger level things right
that it's not just rap but Tom Cruise
you name it dr. Phil I made jewelry for
but like they'll hit me up these young
kids they'll get $100,000 advance and
that come out to go to Ben ball and get
a chance and I'm like a list I'll be
real [ __ ] man maybe you should take care
of your mom's handle a couple things
here and there and get something cool
get like a small cool thing right kill
it kill them suddenly you know I'm
saying shut off and then come back with
a paper gift for real and I'll get right
with you that's dope let me tell you
something listen what are you talking
about that guy that chain about all that
15 years but whenever he saw somebody
had to whoever he made a great chain for
he saw that chain very visual I had a
chain and
you have the money to do it yeah that
will stop him that's his dream yeah what
you stopped them you're gonna kill this
dream yeah yeah no III give so much more
money that money's nothing they're good
sometimes money these guys are gonna get
this money together tran van let them
borrow dude that shit's gonna make them
so they do sometimes they do sometimes a
small percentage of these rappers that
don't really blow they may get their
money stolen but they're gonna make it
that's true to it they were gonna make
so many pans in they pockets but there
was a kid Izzy who was already blown up
Lucy's one of the biggest rappers areas
out there and he was blowing up movie
vert yeah so that's my guy and he just
started bubbling and he's like [ __ ] this
I'm about to get my first chain and I
looked at him and I checked out his
whole style we sat and talked and
usually anybody else you go to these
Russian Jewish news in New York City
like they'll just take the money
it was like listen man you getting to
change from Ben baller that that term
wouldn't be so famous Ben baller did the
chain it's not a [ __ ] number-one song
and in the it was a global song and I
said listen let's sit down that Shane
enhanced his Swagger and ranged
everything for him money would couldn't
do that yeah and he couldn't do that any
text messages he's like yo man you
elevated my career boom and he he
leveled up we got another chain we shut
down Coachella you know like what
jeweler goes on state what you had a TV
show you know I'm saying me like what
jeweler goes on stage at Coachella in
front of 70,000 people you netted me
holding up a chain like you know it was
it was a different thing and you know I
just I tried to give that experience but
sometimes the kid who has no idea and is
premature and I kind of just gave him a
warning listen I just wanna let you know
you sure you want to spend this most you
okay I appreciate that I didn't look at
it like what are you saying - but what
he said is realest [ __ ] because yeah
Busey said I've been looking at your
jewelry since I was 12 and now I can
afford it and I'm like okay cool and it
just worked out that way now what he
said kind of touched me a little bit
more like Dan you might've cuz like [ __ ]
when I wasn't first got my first Ferrari
I walked into Beverly Hills the
[ __ ] like yo you hear to wash a
car and I was like but if you can't get
the [ __ ] out my face what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
I'm here to get a 360 Challenge Stradale
not even like no regulation I'm about to
get some [ __ ] and I took that car and
drove it straight to my hood and I had
my boy worked at Trader Joe's like yo
you gotta get in his car and
five this man this is possible because I
did it well do you know I'm just like no
there's a great boy I was about listen
great point I remember one day we won't
be came from my club we came from a club
one night with a bunch of girls went so
we went in the hotel we all [ __ ] and
drink and did everything and then we as
[ __ ] gorged all night long right we
woke up in the morning we all went down
to the car shop must support around 15
cars yeah hey there's a rumor if you
don't ask
hey brother when you got out when you
got out of jail what year was that 95 95
did you get out the dealership and buy
like 5 or 10 cars right out the dealers
yeah what kind of true man that's crazy
oh I know it sounds silly but for
someone like me who came from nothing to
love kid love cars
do you know even a 95 over here in 95 I
had a Lexus and I thought that was doing
the biggest thing in the world it was a
big deal to me so I heard that rumor I
was like this [ __ ] got out of
jail
straight out of jail didn't go get no
[ __ ] got and bought tank car
whatever it was out the straight how the
penitentiary and I remember like one of
one of the big things in my life is and
then that saying and my wife and me we
argue about it a lot like you know she's
like you know apology goes a long way
with me an apology don't really go too
far with me
you know if you did what you did I know
you're sincere you ain't even got to
tell me it like you know especially I
don't want no fake apology but one thing
is people are too sensitive these days
with social media and everything and I
was like yo Mike never apologize and
remember I was friends with a lot of
people growing up that were not tied you
directly but like one my boy Jaleel my
boy Jamar they dad mr. Anderson was was
right waiting for my man and Jahlil to
the you know they're they're still my
peoples to the day rest in peace mr.
Anderson and he was like amen
we're at Jerry's deli one night he was
like yo Mike is here you want a
three-wheel a trike motorcycle thing and
I was like what the [ __ ] is Mike door on
this tree won't Michael right across for
a Beverly Center Jerry's deli is on this
three-wheeled motorcycles like [ __ ] it I
go out in miss Janice is like you what I
was like nah man
I'm gonna meet Mike one day and it's
gonna be at a point where he remember me
I don't wanna you know boom and like
going back and thinking about it this
dude my boy Shane Mooney his dad's Paul
Mooney the fans up here
so Paul was talking about you when you
was in jail on his tape side two of his
cassette he said you wanna [ __ ] Mike
Tyson he's like you know Mike in jail
they wanted to apologize he ain't gonna
[ __ ] apologize he was like you know
he beat up a co he's like listen you
better pay me back in my cell putting up
the lock on that [ __ ] extra
lock on there and I was like man I love
this dude Mike Tyson so how the while do
back then yeah man you know I did flame
it with the jewelry I work with a bunch
of boxes and stuff but it's like it's a
different type and I hung out with Floyd
a lot it was and he's a cool dude I'm
just saying like man I got to do a toad
piece for Mike yeah toad with the black
bro it be my other plan did you do a
toad chain for Mike yeah we talking
about bro and I'm booked up 20 months
right now I'm 20 months advanced I'm
already booked up paid and I [ __ ]
I'll push people back I don't give a
[ __ ] like that this is a whole different
level this is like you know I'm gonna
pray you me that we think yeah no I mean
listen bro listeners I had an R&B group
signed a party records called the truth
okay and you know you can't have like
that listen this Anderson family was not
a [ __ ] like he had a daughter named
Keisha and his daughter was like my
personal security guard for she would
fight dude I seen her fight grown-ass
men the whole family was just their
pillars crazy so I call Keisha one time
and you says [ __ ] who is this
and I was like a Tony I was like amen my
partner's like a bro like can you talk
to her daddy's trip he goes don't listen
at finally Keisha comes out and she was
like hey you can't just call you got a
knock on my door my dad's old-school
like boom and I was like goddamn but he
like hung up on me cussed me call me all
these kinds of [ __ ] and this and that
and I was like she's like don't trip so
one of my boys
somehow I met early on in my career he
played football he's played for the
brands names Todd light and Todd my
heart oz an old very old friend of my
right Todd's coaching up in
north-northwest now north-northwest and
Todd goes Amy what happened I was
Caucasian man mr. dad cussed me the [ __ ]
outta goes oh he's cussed me out like
1520 times X all over there like you
know he's and he had team Tyson tattoo
you know this dude was a bit you don't
want to this dude was so [ __ ]
connecting the powerful you go to school
and you pick up the kids and it was like
connected everyone but anyways you know
I had a lot of ties to you indirectly
right like you know 1/2 degrees
separation and there was so much respect
that was going on with what you were
doing I just didn't I didn't want to I
felt like I was a peon like I just heard
the Michael Rapaport podcast I listened
to it like four times and some of the
[ __ ] you said on there I can't even say
because man my agent my wife is on some
whole other [ __ ] right now don't talk
about your hoe pass and your criminal do
that but you said a couple things that
hit me so hard that I had to pull over
in my Lamborghini SUV pull over and be
like yo bro he [ __ ] me up like Mike
look like I'm never first of all never
heard you articulate just speak so like
I'm Alexander the Great and everything
and I was like yo man this is a whole
different side so like immediately when
that happened I reached out to everybody
I knew at this point so I'm confident in
my career right now bro what I've done
for Asians I just won the Lifetime
Achievement Award for Asian about the
asian-american wars in December I was a
big thing you know like my mom cried my
mom's never been anyone should see me
clerk the rest did go to jail [ __ ]
get kicked out of schools and my mom was
crying like wow man just do it as a this
dude my my son has actually made it and
I was like every single person I know
time gonna hit my crap poor cuz that's
my boy but I wasn't strong enough we
didn't hear from Frank I didn't man John
Shahidi knew Kiki and John was like
y'all was like y'all broke John she's
our family man yeah yeah and I
introduced John to Justin Bieber yeah I
put them together you know I mean that
guy yeah so John goes listen I owe you
such a favor let me hit them up they're
going to Africa something I was like
listen John I will [ __ ] beat your ass
bro please make this happen I want to
get I want
I don't just mean him I want to be on
this show you know boom what 50 whooping
when I got the email back like it took
like three weeks a month later man bro I
told my wife and she's like that's cool
and I was like because my wife is 11
years younger than me
she knows who my kids but you know she
knows like the like to her your post
tattoo for ya post tattoo on the face
Mike and I'm like you don't know like
that you know Mike knocking mich green
the [ __ ] out the club on the streets you
know I'm saying that might you don't
know my dad for that yeah you know I'm
Steph dapper daily question yeah you
have good about you ever looked at the
history of jewelry what it represents so
I have so I'm in the middle of finishing
a jewelry documentary going all the way
going back to the god god yeah
it's going back but going back all the
way to the Egyptians and I had no idea
how far back the Egyptians went I
thought the Egyptians came a little I'm
talking far back King Tut everything and
just we went from there and then all the
way to like the eighties when people had
the Dookie ropes and I'm saying in
Brooklyn you see there's this one page
as things like Blanco casita something
this duplet all he posts his old-school
like Harlem Brownsville bed-stuy Jews
one big-ass rope chains all real like
real dudes so when I got into the
history of it I was like now I
understand the mass appeal of why people
like I always tell people listen man
first of all good jewelry ain't cheap
cheap jewelry and good you know and
there's a reason why people are wearing
jewelry on the neck and certain things
especially in the inner cities because
you know it represents some total wealth
and everything and when I came on the
first thing I thought was like y'all
wanna get a gold chain on a Rolex and a
BMW that was the first thing I did and
I'm everyone dr. Dre game my first check
it was a big the biggest check I've ever
had at that moment he said hey listen um
[ __ ] I hate saying this and in a certain
way cuz like you know the n-word is
thrown around the hip-hop community so
much you know me and I hated saying like
that because I'll be bigger than you you
it is defined
you can't any shame that you have any
proud of it's big no-no for sure enough
and he was like he was like he was real
deep and he was like pull me to the side
it was like a man you know um we bout to
do something big over here aftermath you
know he's like yo so with this check
what you about to do and I was like wow
you know what you mean he was he was
like yo man don't go out there you know
um did like verbatim he's like don't go
out there and be another [ __ ] he said
don't go out there and spend your [ __ ]
be a [ __ ] fool
and I was like I mean come on why you
how come you ain't talking to everyone
else cuz I'm the only agent ever lost is
black he's like he's like cuz man you
know listen man you special you know you
you you made it this far you you always
the only you know you the token Asian
dude and like just man don't be stupid
right
don't be an n-word and I was like I was
like right with the ER and I was like oh
[ __ ] okay boom what the [ __ ] you think I
did I bought a BMW Rolex the next day
you know I mean of course I did I had to
I never had nothing you know he didn't
speak to me for like a week he's like
man you stupid man and it was like why
would he do the same thing I know he did
but he's trying to like you know show
and I had to then I remember I lost
everything before I turned I was broke
twice before I was 30 then I made my
first million I was 31 and just from
there I never looked back I nightmares
like especially with kids now and
everything I was like nah [ __ ] that I
want them to be okay for a minute but
going back to it I'll ask people
questions not about the history and I
back a listen why is that chain means so
much to me things like oh man and
everyone has a different answer but the
most of it is because like yo man
because I feel like I made it you know
I'm saying this [ __ ] make me feel it's
like a superpower it's like Batman
putting on a suit do you know what makes
them feel it makes it feel royal it
makes them feel grand it makes them feel
[ __ ] it it puts their swag if you see
dudes with a lot of chains on they
swagger is different do you know they
yeah they have a power they have a you
know they feel majestic yeah you know
the whole the whole the whole objective
is it the feel that way without the jury
100% you know but if the jury make you
feel like we get to jury because you
need to feel that way yeah I mean people
see me they think I was yeah you need to
feel that way but you need to feel that
without to jury yeah people think I'm
aware like 50 chains on a regular basis
now because that was me like 10 15 years
ago but people are like I wear a watch
my wedding ring that I made in my
earrings you know but I keep a real
chill but very classy and people like
I'm wearing the Allah because it's a
it's Ramadan I'm reppin my people I just
got back from Dubai and I got a lot of
Arab folks and Muslim people and like
people who I want to show love to I'm
not necessarily tied to one religion you
know and like I just believe there is a
God and I believe that all religions
somehow you know twined with each other
and it's more of a respect thing so I
was like you know what man let me go
ahead and I made this Diamond Allah
peace let me let me rock this for the
people and you know Muslims don't wear
yellow gold they can't wear you know
yellow so it's like I made in the right
color I was like let me let me just show
look I was about to ask them that was
why I was gonna act my thing
why did that um Platinum is more
expensive than gold but people want to
really yellow go white gold but they
want the yellow go why's that because
this it shows off his show either a she
you know it's mom flashy it's not loud
no he's right if you think about it
yellow gold hits you can see it from so
far Wells more than Oh way more way more
than way more and you know um how'd you
get into diamonds man
so from music to diamonds this is crazy
so I um I left the music business and
while I was in the music business my
uncle he he learned to trade as a
jeweler as a bench jeweler meaning like
he's actually physically doing a lot of
goldsmith work and everything and his
son and me were the only ones that were
kind of cool he was the only person that
smoked weed with me and he's three years
younger than me so he hit me up he's
like a man introduce me to some people
like Bone Thugs and like dr. Dre knee
back and make jewelry you know this
forget this going I was like alright he
made a piece and it wasn't that great
and I was like [ __ ] come on like we
[ __ ] it's we welcomed with big dogs
you know saying I saw around 2004 I was
getting I was engaged and [ __ ] I never I
never talked about this ever I'm I've
done every interview could think of
Breakfast Club late night you just Late
Show I've never broke - never talked
about this but I've said that I was
engaged but so I got caught cheating on
my ex-fiance and she was super model and
she was in Milan doing a show and she
was like how come you want to come boom
I was feeling myself you know I just
sold my sneaker collection for three
million dollars you know I had paper
boom but I was like I was ready I not
music I'm just I don't have to wake up
in the morning and I was doing this
video shoot I was a co-star Littlejohn's
the video shoot with Ice Cube and she's
like you're gonna stay for a video shoot
and I'm like babe I'm not trying to sit
around like who you're like lack you
know manlier cuz like you know was like
I went to a lot of her shows whatever so
she's in she's in Italy and she would
call me every night back then itself
wasn't kind of the same you know I mean
like you call it from a house phone and
she'd hit me every time at the SIRT at
the same time
and I didn't pick up the phone it was
like midnight and um she called my
cellphone I didn't pick up the phone and
I was in Vegas [ __ ] around actin
tough you know the mean just being a
scumbag piece of [ __ ]
and she found she didn't find out she
just called being human yeah
her energy was so on point I never spoke
about this before she knew [ __ ] was off
so at that point it was doomed so I went
through a real miserable time when we
had broke up she called off the
engagement I was embarrassed my family
you know she they don't know why to the
month less they list my mom listen to
this [ __ ] she's 75 your cream machine
listen to this [ __ ] like she can barely
handle an iPhone but she um you know my
wife might hear this and be like man you
didn't tell me that [ __ ] but like you
know I [ __ ] up so I was in a
transition in my life what am I gonna do
now I can't sit like I'm not gonna
invest it when my like I need to figure
out what to do next so I said [ __ ] man
travel the world I went to like 25
different countries that was where I
traveled the most and I said um I met my
cousin Steve up see what the [ __ ] he's
doing so I go down the Schloss and you
know right by an FC store I go to
infants Lawson and my cousins there and
he's like you know I'm doing well he had
a Corvette and you know whatever out and
I was like okay so how does this really
work and he was like you know boom here
and there and a lot of things with
Koreans jewelry yes yes a lot of things
with Korean people they don't believe in
contracts they believe in a handshake
and that shit's good and that just how
it goes you know and my uncle pulls up
and he's like hey so what are you doing
here you know how's your mom blah blah
and our family's in turmoil all our
family don't speak to each other because
of money and stupid [ __ ] you know what I
mean it's not stupid but money [ __ ] off
families doesn't mean one person
immigrated here it brings the rest and
then like people are doing well and then
like one borrows money from someone else
they don't pay back so bottom line is my
uncle and my mom kind of having a funk
and I remember he would trade with my
mom and give her joy my love my mom
loved jewelry that's where I got my
first infatuation with jewelry seeing my
mom rocket my mom was a hustler
so going on I met my cousin and I mean
I've been up with my cousin he was like
yo you want to [ __ ] around with and
check it out he goes there's some good
money in it he says you have over a lot
of music clients you have a lot of
celebrities already you know I told you
before he goes I was like okay but if I
come in it I want to buy in one third me
your dad you know you 3333 and I don't
want to be in this that even
we moved next door into the next booth I
just want to do that so we fresh start
all together I don't want this like oh
no we're gonna go everything cool we'll
split 50-50 now because if there's no
contract there's no nothing there's no
cooperation I don't want to have the
drama I'd rather be your friend and lose
you out you know I'm saying and then you
know [ __ ] up business we started that
that's why I became a jeweler and I hit
up everyone I know sls on making jewelry
now now I had it took about two years to
get perfect perfect with it but my uncle
was cold with it super cold with the
jewelry with the hand skills and the
carving designing and I was already a
pretty detailed intricate person and
everything so my boy at the time was was
dating where I carry and they're they
gotta fight for years and I was like hey
listen bro you you got to give me a
chance man they make more I carry a
chain and he's a con man you know she
deals with Jacob you know she deals with
Cartier's do this I was a gay and I know
[ __ ] but if I make something
proper like the real [ __ ] I was talking
big [ __ ] I was like yo I can make a dope
ass MC have a logo send me the logo sons
Brazil logo I make the chain
sure enough more I carry my first level
D client give it to her um you know well
she bought it and she warden in her bone
thugs collab video ever and then I'm
right after that I started working with
the clips push the T and malice you know
I mean and they're from Virginia
hardcore hardcore hip-hop dudes made
their change that was a big deal then
from there Jacob got arrested he was
embezzling money for BMF you know I'm
saying so we went to jail basically all
these people from like Scott Soares did
he like nos the game everyone started
migrating from Jacob to me so a lot of
pressure I was like yo we got to get
this popping then I was I don't want me
to be in their music videos and this and
and I said listen I need to not only
make the best jewelry but if my prices
are fair no one's gonna want to go with
me that's outside of hip-hop I need to
be bigger than this [ __ ] I need to be I
need making the [ __ ] that the
King of Pop all these people I had all
these people I wanted to make jewelry
for and I said listen I'll get to them I
had basically created this was my space
at the time I had created this image and
everything else and I was like you know
I don't want to beat your prices I want
to beat your work because in 1986 my mom
wanted to buy a Rolex and my mom did we
lived in a [ __ ] two-bedroom apartment
you know I mean like
thousand square feet which is big but
that was like us doing it you know and
my brother and sister going to school
you know over over you know on
scholarship in high school and she would
go to Rodeo Drive on a Monday and like
random days to go look at this watch and
the storm would deal drivers call Fred
and Mike was there buying something and
he was buying like millions of dollars
and this is a teasing you know a million
dollars Dan's like [ __ ] ten million
dollars now and I was like mom I'm
saying don't you think the watch is
beautiful said man mom I'm not even
think about the watch right now it's
Mike Tyson she's like oh yeah Mike Tyson
is he's a he's an awesome guy I was like
mom that's you name of no man whatever
he's getting I want whatever you're
getting on aminos like some crazy [ __ ]
but we're outside the store you were
inside the store at Fred on Rodeo Drive
Fred yeah so you know it was like I've
had a history with jewelry and now that
I've gone to this level of where I'm at
now I just got tired of it cuz there's
so many Instagram jewelers at [ __ ]
[ __ ] they have no office front they
faking it they've taken pictures of
people of my pieces and losses pieces
I'm like yo I can make this you want to
buy it boom I'm like yo man don't do
that cornball [ __ ] you know I'm saying
oh he's trying to get on you hungry you
thirsty like but don't take my [ __ ] like
or shout me out of something you know I
didn't do that [ __ ] I need a bull
[ __ ] when I was trying to get on you
know I made it [ __ ] myself myself I use
my own resources so like you got a
million jeweler's out there who who just
biting and stealing and they want some
punk [ __ ] and they've been approached
before and a couple of them but like yo
man I don't think you know where I'm
from bro you know I mean you get [ __ ]
up for stupid [ __ ] like this and then
they go call an attorney I get a [ __ ]
lawsuit hit me with so it's like it's
it's a catch-22 but where it is now is I
said I'm not gonna do this [ __ ] anymore
and my cousin's like nah know what the
[ __ ] you talking about work you don't
work we're huge when you're talking
about a man doing this [ __ ] so to stop
that I said listen make a little small
part on the website and say if you want
to get a custom Ben baller chain you
need to pay $100,000 up front and then
from there you'll have access to a cell
phone you can hit him up you go through
the design process boom hit posters
showing you my Instagram because I'm the
highest follow jewel on Instagram and
I've been for a while and like boom will
go to this process I did that [ __ ] man
and [ __ ] twelve orders came in and I
was like [ __ ] man I don't want to work
and now I just put myself into a year I
just signed a gear contract so what I
did was the first time I returned
everyone's money and a lot of them went
to a Duff
different people and they're like [ __ ]
this dude been balls on some other [ __ ]
and I was like no I got a step because
I've always stepped away and when you
look in the rearview mirror if you keep
seeing people kind of close or carnival
I don't want to see nobody in my
rearview mirror you know so I was like
[ __ ] this so I just raised the price and
I was like listen man if someone got
something dope that's pushing the bar
like if you just want to make a Mercedes
Benz chain with diamonds come on man you
know like doc you know you wasting my
time like I want to do some innovative
[ __ ] you know I mean oh yeah towed
whatever the [ __ ] it is it could be you
know anything but um you know I'm at
that level now where you know uh you
know I'm good I have my own jewelry line
you know yeah I was about to tell you
it's good to have people in your mirror
you have to remind them why they're back
there that [ __ ] kind of scared me though
matter of fact no never mind then why
they're back there yeah that's why I'm
like [ __ ] I gotta keep running I got a
key I are gonna keep driving I had to
keep pushing you know like um I'm gonna
take that into consideration though yeah
cuz there's some people on my bumper
right now I need to belong on your
bumper yeah if you don't see them they
can't motivate you not you know when you
seem oh I got a good hello there getting
close but that's the closest they're
gonna get mmm
no that's [ __ ] that's Thank You Man now
that's some good advice there yeah Wow
any question yeah
what's the most expensive you've ever
made I made a 10 million dollar ring for
a Saudi uproar Sultan well and he was
crazy cuz 10 mil and I could never post
it I can never show in fact till then I
don't even know I should know I'm sure I
can say that but yeah it was for Sultan
and it was crazy because I feel private
jets to Vegas to like New York this was
the only time I ever flew private
overseas and was worst experience my
entire life now listen man I get if you
become super famous like I can't walk to
the mall with that getting stock I can't
go to the airport and stop 20 times
every day someone takes a picture cool
but I know when you're like Chris Brown
or someone who aren't even him it's
tough to fly commercial I get it you
know I mean
I love foreign commerce I love flying
commercial too I love I love the people
my kids I was gonna play one it's only
us this time
and I hate that fast now we're gonna go
with the people I love the people we're
going to the Middle East
imagine fly to the Middle East and you
plan it on a jet and it's the worst
experience and on top of that had to
stop and refuel and like was just [ __ ]
up then I get out there man it just
happened to be a really bad time I was
hot and everything else I was like yo
man boom and then I just thought about I
was like yo man the wire just hit and I
thought about I was like wow man that's
some crazy-ass [ __ ] and like it was like
one week out of every year that he would
cop jewelry from me you know like I'm
his daughter's cop jewelry from me and
everything but like um that was most
expensive piece and you were like okay
the bad flight that might have been
worth it no I was but I don't like
flying peer yeah yeah like I got
zip-tied on on the way to uh to South
Africa I was gonna join I was gonna Cape
Town in Johannesburg I got zip tied
after like 13 hours because I was doing
push-ups in the first class and I was
like hey man I've watched every episode
of Fresh Prince on the plane I was like
you know I'm starting so I started
taking some oxygen and then the
stewardess was like hey you know um we
have to save this one as much oxygen for
the rest of the camp I'll give you
$60,000 can't just do me a favor don't
ever talk to me ever again and let me
have this oxygen thing and then right
then they zip-tied me and put me in the
[ __ ] and I was like all right so how the
[ __ ] am I gonna get back to America back
home I'm in South Africa right and I was
like alright well you know I'm gonna do
I'm just gonna live here and I was
thinking okay I can fly to here then fly
to Egypt then from Egypt to Greece and
Greece to London then let's a short
flood yes I was tripping I discovered
ambien took ambien flew back but yeah I
don't really like flying you know so
that was like another thing but of
course I'm with you bro do you know yeah
that was that was most expensive like
the trip you had to do a lot of those
yeah I just got back from Dubai I'm are
you gonna do buy before plenty of time
you call these long trips me next
painting they on these long chips you
talking to somebody you don't know and
next thing you know you're in the
private car with a [ __ ] trip
it's a trip like for the trip human
being interacting with each other they
don't even know each other strangers
that's the trip but let me ask you a
question man what when'd you start
smoking weed listen I'm gonna tell you a
story about this this is interesting I
smoke weed all my life but I started at
8 and my mother used to freight my
mother friends used to give me weed they
make me sleep to make me go to sleep
we the liquor man make me go to sleep
and so I just been doing it all my life
and then around 15 I stopped because I
wanted to be a buck you know well 18 I
stopped because I want to really fight I
started fighting and I lost an Olympic
Trials and I started getting parent I
must because I'm too much weed right so
that I started fighting I stopped I
stole I stopped smoking 1984 from 1984
to around 19 1991
I guess 98 fourteen years 90 I'm one to
park down 96 96 97 because I smoked that
time first time I smoked since I'm 14
years Tupac died I went over this house
and I started smoking again well I never
stopped Wow she took 14 years off
yeah and so on and one day I smoked
during the fight you know and it was the
best fight ever had a broken nose
cheekbone I thought could back rib it
was incredible fearless move in doing
this all along I start tripping out when
I found out that a lot of NBA players
are smoking like before the game and
everything oh yeah how the [ __ ] cuz when
I get real high I can't get [ __ ] like
I'm like brought need to get a driver
boom here but like you know I learned to
obviously manage how to become
productive it's all the thing right I
played in some NFL games we great all
kinds of drugs are meant to be used and
not abused yeah yeah I know how to use
some of most of us abuse the drugs you
know you just smoke up smoke a nice
drink nice plump bump let's go in the
ring now and it feels good it's good
luck you know something you smoke so
much one Joey I'm ready to go yeah no
that's my favorite thing this
okay and then go into the gym yeah you
know I I just trust depending on you
know what I'm doing I'm sorry that's
right to go back I got a a butyl mommy
ask a manager who's who's that who's
that the the biggest celebrity or the
craziest let you smoke the smoke with no
[ __ ] Evan Britton [ __ ] weird snoop in
here watch the show
have you watched toxin I watched Piers
Morgan because at a certain point Moke
for the first time here yeah for the
first for the for a point I don't know
what it was y'all were talking and
everything and it break down I thought
Mike was gonna punch him a $10 I call
secure funding you were stuck that I was
weird I just couldn't read it you know
that means they were gonna make those
hitting people no more no more no man I
just I just - all of these things no no
I know you know my wife has been
vegetarian for 16 17 years and when I
had stomach surgery almost five years
ago five years ago I had stomach surgery
and I don't what the [ __ ] happened there
just like just eat light whatever blah
blah and then I kind of went vegetarian
for a lot of months and with pescetarian
I had no more stomach issues and then I
started introducing other things but
then I realized you know I know I heard
you're on a vegan lifestyle now right oh
yeah listen we died back because of what
we eat
I thought can we die amen listen bro
again this this is this is [ __ ]
amazing because it's awesome well first
of all like yeah just connecting with
you connecting with other people here
and I've talked to Cody a lot on on on
DM and everything else and just again
with Mike like I'm such a big [ __ ]
boxing fan like you know back in the day
that was you were way before your time
but there was select TV you know Nemean
or on TV was like that was the only she
kabocha I watched Tommy Hearns brain was
going yeah and I'm watching you know
yeah
and I'm talking about like I've never
seen anybody do this type of [ __ ] in
here with the other one I'm like come on
man and I always thought like you don't
be a bad mother [ __ ] box I was like
that was never my thing do you know I
don't okay when check one dole but like
you know um the best Asian box of the
Japanese they're the [ __ ] best oh
they're good yeah
and that probably they can compete the
best Asian fight ever so like the
Taiwan's in the Japanese interesting
when they could fight there's a [ __ ]
bath
they got long rings like 20 title
defenses this [ __ ] like that you know
when I'm good they got the [ __ ] I got
I got another theist he was funny so Lou
Adler owns the Roxy on top of the Roxy
was a legendary place that Jack
Nicholson the Lakers Heidi Fleiss had
her thing is called on the rocks it's a
very legendary place so we closed it
down for the meet Peter McNeeley I was
never coming back right and he goes hey
we're shutting the entire Club down I
was like for what he goes Michael Jordan
is coming up to watch this with Damon
Wayans and it was Lou Adler Mike Michael
Michael Jordan Damon Wayans me and Nick
Adler and the bartender that was there
and that was it and that [ __ ] was crazy
because it ended so [ __ ] fast he's
trying to [ __ ] kill him you know I
mean and that was a big thing all your
fights were a big deal do you know the
mean and like even like when I was in
high school I remember um when I was in
high school and when you were in Tokyo
that situation happened I didn't want to
bring on them and I thought about it was
such a big fan that I didn't look at it
as a I didn't look at as a bad thing for
you
I took it to heart like it affected me
like I was so upset for the rest of now
we're headed to a house party I had a
bag of like munchies I had weed I had
alcohol I was ready to go get [ __ ]
probably some [ __ ]
I was I was lit and then that happened
and I was like man [ __ ] my whole night
up cuz I was like yo I was so
heartbroken because I was like yo and I
wasn't gonna [ __ ] that
so it was like that's how deep a bit of
an impact you have to where I was like
yo man like I [ __ ] with you that heavy
and again man yeah if I didn't take my
losses you right if I didn't take my
losses could you never get those losses
again not that way yeah you know you
learn from my losses
yeah you feel that fight what a fight
yeah how are you feeling just an
arrogant [ __ ] he's gonna die I'm
gonna kill this [ __ ]
really
yeah what missin what what time was the
fight at it was like it was 9 p.m. so
that means it was like I didn't train I
could have trained better but you know
my mind was now how hard I train your
mind wasn't really I was [ __ ] all the
ladies these guys listen this is what my
promoter does right
since I'm I'm up in my room and I've
known the [ __ ] all this [ __ ] cleaning
ladies I'm normally a [ __ ] [ __ ] all
the cleaning lady so um they get all the
cleaning ladies off listen you get all
the cleaning ladies off my floor and
they put a bunch of old [ __ ] Japanese
[ __ ] on my floor right so I [ __ ] them
- oh my god your average bro ya know
back then this [ __ ] my 23 Wow would
you say before that fight you kind of
just didn't give a [ __ ] you didn't give
a [ __ ] about it really yeah but listen I
mean it's gonna be a been a couple of
fights big fights I didn't give a
[ __ ] knock these mother yeah and a
lot of these guys was just so
intimidated that Presta pressured hold
event was just overwhelming and I would
[ __ ] with them and talk to them and bad
to them in the scare but you know what
was dope this is what was cool Buster
Douglas just end up [ __ ] flop doing
being like 500 pounds you know my fellow
and I say that's good for him but I'm
saying is that was a fluke win by him
you don't say any calm mic on an off
night it wasn't like on some like it was
that's how I looked at it like would you
look like this that's the best that's
something like you said he went to hell
that's that's a big responsibility there
kills people yeah it drives them insane
drove me insane having a heavyweight
championship and you can't imagine it
what am I saying now however no I know
this there's no way in this [ __ ]
planet I can kick my ass you want to
hear that you just imagine it [ __ ] you
could say this is your that individual
yeah you doctor yeah you could say that
because you're in that position to say
that
so you think of [ __ ] how long did you
stay in Japan and after that I left
right away that the next night oh [ __ ]
okay
I'm feeling that huh how'd you feel like
I felt relieved
Wow I felt relieved a lot of pressure
relief and [ __ ] Wow I can't wait to go
to my good my girlfriend house pick up
my car needs to go out and just let them
heal me up cuz I had a big guy so I let
me hang out hung up for a while to my I
went down there still blacking my eyelid
you got some [ __ ] after the fight yeah
I was just an animal I didn't understand
I was my life that's what I thought life
was about oh I was a walking hormone no
this is terrible I know this is so bad
my wife is gonna be like why the [ __ ]
did you say that and she does even know
cuz she don't listen to the mic rapport
Mike Tyson podcast when you said you
like damn [ __ ] man I'm I must have AIDS
or something blah blah whatever but I
went to the doctor so much that the
Ducks I was I was up for an Asian dude
like I was the only Asian in college and
then I mean I was I was playing football
basketball I'm like you know like I had
swagger you know I was running with Dre
you know thought I was the [ __ ] right so
I would get I would get you know I would
get I would get [ __ ] on off on a
regular basis in like I didn't think
about it for a long time she had to back
then it was like common the kind of raw
dog ain't got a kind of my [ __ ] who
cares and I remember I said yo I didn't
feel good for like three months as a
kill America HIV bro [ __ ] I'm sick I
go to the doctor he's like yo you don't
have that and I was like all right let
me get tested so finally this day I'll
never forget dr. Gould in Century City
he's like you have nothing and that they
didn't let me come to the office no more
like this you're crazy and as well you
get your dick sucked and you know you
don't know person and I was asking crazy
questions and like just crazy [ __ ] and I
was like yo and then when I found out
like I was good good like I was just
like yo man and like um it you know I'm
just saying you know what I mean like
it's just that it just I thought about
what you said
oh listen dr. Gould I'm in Jamaica I got
a strip I'm [ __ ] if I have a rubber we
haven't pulled the rubber bus boom and
listen when a bus right I'm like [ __ ] it
bus and the girl looked and she starts
crying so I'm thinking why is she crying
she crying cuz you think I'm giving
husband diseases she's crying because
she had the disease and she gave it to
me [ __ ] why this [ __ ] crying at the
rubber bus
yeah yeah how was that long time ago a
long time ago I was yeah my thirties
long maybe four legs but yeah [ __ ] imma
die oh no oh [ __ ] man dude so so crazy I
mean it's dis oh man that's do tell us
about this bro yeah I didn't bring a
flower it's more of a luxury Brown and
like kind of if you got people got kids
I don't want to smell like weed you know
really nice packaging yeah VVS well VBS
is me okay so I'm a jeweler right yes
VBS is the ticket so it's the highest
quality diamond and all my pens they
look like jewelry Gina I'm saying like
they look really really classy you know
super high-end you know and so I brought
some I brought some dope things yeah but
I'm sure over yeah well you think that's
that's really what people want to be
they want to not even feel howleen they
want to look high in let that upper
echelon type of people look at that look
at that let me take off the top so this
is a Cecil this is the this is like the
the BMW mercedes banz of quality of Penn
what are their inhaling just hit it
that's mango mint yeah hit that [ __ ]
whoo that's a big hip orange sorbet or
so based dope and let me taste some this
has more
this has more THC content obviously they
have no child protect you have to know
because if you don't which ones that or
so man that's my new favorite flavor
actually orange sorbet
yeah that's my new favorite side
Academy's been this so this is the thing
man and and you know some people know
some people don't you know isocell we do
legally insane I used I used to
transport dope to Atlanta to [ __ ] um
to Ohio mostly Ohio and uh you know hit
then try that out
so I misspoke a weed almost all my life
I stopped for a while - I had an
eight-year break
um and we won't get into that because it
was a bad situation of why I [ __ ]
[ __ ] we'll get into it one night I was
smoking out the bong and I sided snowcap
it was so nice well super hit clean
really nice lady Coco Puffs and I'm
hitting it to be a Coco puff err yeah so
then my chest start going real my heart
was going really fast and my boys would
be knows April do me a favor make you
take my heart rate and it wasn't like
some Friday [ __ ] I knew my [ __ ] was
[ __ ] up and my boys a good friend dude
he goes nah man it's cool bro you're
tripping you know you're good and I was
a guy right and I knew it wasn't good so
I went I put my head in the fridge in
the freezer and I sat in there for a
minute
I just couldn't focus i call 9-1-1 well
and my heart rate was going 300 beats
per minute talking about he was doing
that so I wouldn't so I could calm down
you know I mean he was trying to calm me
down
so anyways every time I smoke weed after
that it triggered that feeling hmm so I
was like man [ __ ] this [ __ ] but I never
got back into it going on I I'm a
business man you know and I've been in
this business for a long time I know
what it is and for it to be legal
I wanted somehow to get into it so I saw
my buddy who was like one day the poor
J's in mind but they kind of looked up
to me growing up but these guys have
dudes now who I idolized you know I mean
like these are younger guys than me who
are killing it crushing it and they've
built a conglomerate in the cannabis
business and no one even knows they've
been so good about being low-key about
it but they hit me with this vape pen
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
they're like you travel a lot I was like
yeah I go to Asia and he goes you can't
bring flour with you the Asian you know
you can't I was like no you right when
snoop went to Korea
I got him every single bit of cushion
you could get in the entire country and
he was like he called me snoop was like
you my [ __ ] dog will if you get
caught with weed out there oh oh yeah
doc you got remember some place so they
kill you but in Korea there's no jail
cells over 4 feet tall can't stand up in
your cell you [ __ ] you got a bucket like
and anyways you know I broke it down but
anyways going on I was like yo I want
something discreet I want to build so it
looks like jewelry looks expensive looks
luxurious the same for the dude who's
saving up well I got $20 I'm gonna get a
joint and let me get some weed no that's
not the clan of going after I'm going
off to you know I'm saying that the Elon
Musk
type of people you know someone who's
born out of control that don't want to
you know a lot of celebrities that soak
smoke my pens they like it cuz it looks
like makeup or it looks like the girls
they don't want to look like boom so you
know when I made these pens I want to be
high quality the best possible
extraction the best oils you know the
best mechanics everything so you know I
even gave you just one of it what do our
pens looking like man how's our pins
looking our pins yeah with that the cut
from dude we're doing some stuff with
pax pax is cool yeah I got I was in
Tucson with pax just um and there they
got but it was not like how I wanna say
I'm not gonna say anything bad it's not
necessarily bad it's just I didn't your
opinion man yeah yeah yeah I just felt
like I'd be promoting pax more than I'd
be promoting my own brand yeah because
you have to use their mechanism so going
on this is gorilla glue and I love
grilling Lou and so this is my Bentley
key yeah so you do that and this is like
super sonic Justin
by the way Mike just so you know if you
go to a Laker game and go to a Dodger
game go to Knicks whatever you go to if
one if you have one or two pounds in
your pocket don't take about your pocket
go through this metal detector
these will bypass them had just enough
metal put in there too and it has a
built-in USB charger those are companies
diamonds shape them and I know those are
10 milligrams each yeah they're chill
THC to make you feel good oh man so this
I brought you this key so it looks like
a Bentley key right and you just go boom
and then you just hit the button and you
hit it just hit this throat and it's
smoke comes out boom it's powerful it's
got my Ben baller logo on there you know
brought you that out there when you're
gonna be able to do some [ __ ] where guys
cuz you know like oh you know um
crystallize tha yet we got we got a lot
of different stuff going on though man
we got um I have a syrup I didn't know
how deep into us you were so I was gonna
give you this syrup that I have right
you put up a surprise [ __ ] delicious
right what do you do about stick up
all that kind of stuff you never had
anybody try to extort you anything
somebody tried exploiting one time man
to talk about that [ __ ]
I had a dude but you look at the [ __ ]
war you know yeah yeah come on man bro
you know I grew up I grew up in gangs
all my life don't see how we get down
have to bring that so you know I'm good
there but you [ __ ] you hang around much
for him yeah I some Jews hit me up and
then it was crazy because I ran my black
people almost all my life on that side
so the Asian gangsters from my hood they
didn't really appreciate that which I
understand I understand you know why
they're like a man you know you run with
them boom whatever so I had hate coming
from both sides when I made it like all
you don't come back to k-town no more
you know I'm saying you [ __ ] running
with this this and this but you know
what come back and I was like you know
and the funny thing it was worse on the
asian son on the korean side than it was
on the on a black side but I remember um
I told this dude uh naw man you know
[ __ ] you like I mean I you know I'm down
to give you a good deal I'm gonna take
care of you and I'm saying but I'm not
breaking you off no paper with [ __ ]
in a break for what I got Brahma groan I
got kids like I'm almost possibilities
[ __ ] you're talking about he goes ok ok
I'm gonna see you and I remember I
pulled up on this corner Robertson in
Beverly like right a block away from the
Ivy restaurant and I'm in my Ferrari and
I'm sitting out a life family he boiling
there he came boiler area code and [ __ ]
and I'm at I'm at the lights 4:30 and
afternoon and I looked to the side of
the window do pulling a gun on me well
young cat he had a hood on he had a gun
right at the window and I'll tell you
exactly how it was whoa house chilling
right here looking for the light looking
at the light I was looking over here
look over here looked over here I see
the gun at me said man I wasn't scared
at all whatsoever I said man this
[ __ ] man I wish I wasn't in this
car right now it's awful I just got this
brand-new for hours I was like I'm gonna
[ __ ] this car and I thought about it and
I looked over again and then I saw the
gun and the barrel the gun was all
[ __ ] up like beat up and that's when I
got I got scared I was like [ __ ] man
it's that time finally it's finally my
time I talked to all this [ __ ] I done
did this I didn't flourish I didn't die
I lived this is my time I'm gone you
gonna kill me you know I'm saying so I'm
but the dude dude was like roll the
window down [ __ ] brought a
window down and I looked the dude right
and he was like oh [ __ ] man he was like
yeah yeah you are a Ben baller and he's
like a man
give me a watch and I was like not this
watch man you know I'm saying I'm bout
to whatever boom and then we had got
into it and then it was too much
discussion so he was Hugh striking
paranoid and people are honking at me
behind me they thought we were just
talking I'm saying they're honking and
now I look forward and there was a car
and it had brand-new plates on it was
like an old Japanese SUV like the mini
SUV and I looked back and as a dude like
this make sure you think cool bro we in
an area where you don't want to [ __ ]
around this area to be the dumbest
[ __ ] people in the world didn't I
realise later they was tied up - oh boy
from my old hood I was trying to hit me
a paper
[ __ ] yeah and he was just like you know
it's [ __ ] up I got people looking out
for me dawg you know I'm not saying I'm
not saying ah invincible here's another
another style pen it's just beautiful
that we can get into I can I brought you
it's also oh that's - yeah all luxury
rose gold yellow gold white gold oh we
ballin this mother listen know what I
wonder it since the beginning of time
even cavemen found something to
stimulate them here what was it some why
is it that we need that not everybody
why do them the majority of the world
need that I don't know I'd love to get
[ __ ] up I know it sounds terrible but
I mean I'm responsibly it's nobody
because we want to be high we want to
connect the spirit really um I think
they concern about ourselves or you're
feeling a whole sometimes in a way it's
not about money anything I realized that
a certain point man money just buy his
convenience it's not gonna change
anything I could be upset about whatever
but I do realize sometimes at the world
I feel like I'm almost even on below I
don't feel so that when I get [ __ ] up
I get elevated and I feel above it
that's how I feel you know me personally
but I have a question that that goes
with that like
I have to be young kids I got my lights
I got my life started late so you know I
got a six year old a five year old and a
almost two year old right I can't get
too [ __ ] up around them when they
sleep I'm late I'm out when you when you
had when you were raising your kids did
you ever get you ever like really high
and being with them yeah I know that I
have a son that's 21 I would do this 23
and I see myself talking I'm smoking no
whether to take the drink Wow you
smoking I give it to him but I don't say
anything good right if I do it
it's not bad for them to do so how about
when they were like six five or seven or
eight - Jared smoke weed were you ever
high when they were they were young I've
been high on cocaine at time to my couch
I mean back in the day that I've always
been high around my kids but now we have
a different understanding me my kids we
went to therapy together and now we just
didn't do life together you know I'm so
happy that we have a relationship if it
wouldn't if they wouldn't turn out the
way it did we wouldn't had a
relationship well as I get older in life
I'm just I'm just cool with not being
right and just being okay like I mean
the relationship with my kids that's my
main well maybe this is something that's
been very lucrative for me this is a
great thing we get to also you know do
some cool charities and and you know
it's it's I love what the brand
represents but my question is um what
would you what made you want to get into
inter and cannabis
well listen I never really anticipate
getting into cannabis you know my
brother-in-law and us we bought a
dispensary right right and I was telling
my own thing that was a good idea for my
experience with it's been three at that
time this is during the boom of weed and
oh yeah Rob's and a lot of people but I
was doing a movie five years ago I
believe
I brought my partner here and him my
brother-in-law was talking about getting
into the weed business and he informed
me and gave me the ins and out and that
so it was a no-brainer
that's what we do no brainer yeah I know
this is um this is another this is
another form of cash flow in this world
and the planet and just the fact that um
we got in a very infantile stage at the
beginning stage getting our license and
stuff and that's very difficult to do
right now it's really tough I mean we
got an early thing cob yeah almost
impossible to do right now yeah and we
did have a great operation we have a
great team of people with men if you
don't mind later when they finish I'll
show you around what we plan on demand I
got the rest of them [ __ ] yeah it's good
I got everything taken god I've been
looking forward for this day for it
since the the email so I've been juiced
about it I've been I've been super hyped
um I want to ask you just because I'm
such a big boxing fan right like what do
you think about the boxing like boxing
or how box we're boxing is today boxing
today is all about show business now
it's not about getting the best fighter
than putting again see who's the best
fighter in the world yeah not about
macho is not about that who's bad who is
about who makes the most money who's
gonna make the most money how do we get
the best fight for these well how do you
feel about these judges calling these
close fights like like that triple G
Canelo fight like [ __ ] like that
I think that's having to do with judges
just not knowing what the [ __ ] they're
looking at you don't think they're
corrupt neither I'm definitely at two
but I think mostly they don't know the
[ __ ] they're looking at some crazy [ __ ]
man just to see but like um do you okay
do you think today if you were in your
prime you were 21 right now your prior
twenty-one yeah and you shot yourself
into the future to 2019 and how to fight
one of these big heavyweights like Josh
was someone like that I live in them I
hate to think of no you have to ask them
I don't I don't know listen I'm a
different I was a different kind of a
person and stuff I wasn't a nice guy
he's a nice guy that was me and I wanna
attack my spit on them and stuff I don't
know how would that affect that psychic
I know but I'm saying do you think you
you see you'd still be the champ today
don't you think for sure yeah I would
like to think that my ego tells me that
yeah okay yeah who do you like right now
like an like doesn't matter middleweight
welterweight heavyweights
if the guy out there
the cholo brothers a [ __ ] dynamite
fighters - okay - you know those guys I
barely hello brother these are some bad
love for the twin the both champion it
bad yeah the twin see I should fight
Canelo and those guys these I would like
to see what happened these guys are
fighters man right and I miss this
little guy you cause you know the guys
from Ukraine needs to master limit
chenko oh yeah of course yeah he's the
best
and that I got a guy catching up with
him that he's gonna have to fight when
this guy call do you have on Tate Davis
you me of him called tank yeah of course
that before me and him down to a little
argument on how to fight him and limit
chenko argument on Twitter he says some
[ __ ] after after Mikey I'll be after
Pacquiao Broner
Pacquiao beat Broner and he was saying
some [ __ ] and I was like I will let's
bet a chain on it you know I'm saying
because he was like the old me next
you know Javon - versus versus versus
Pacquiao and as a guy well it was a bit
of chain on it he's like you got to be a
million-dollar chain I'm like
[ __ ] mean dog training [ __ ]
come on bro let's get this baby back
people in his life yeah you know but
like uh he's a bad [ __ ] yeah but
you know until he fight he's bad I know
but till he fights the Ukrainian limit
chenko he's not number one yeah okay
well yeah no I just I just curious I was
that was something that brought up and I
was like wow man it's it's been a minute
since I've done an interview this lit I
feel good right now
like I feel [ __ ] amazing we have a
good time in here man no this is this is
crazy this is just again man one being
with one of my my top idol legends you
know I'm saying I'm not starstruck from
nobody I've met but we how do you drive
your car or how do you get around in
your car oh that's okay so you know you
how you fight with with the whip and you
how you could play football yeah I get
in the car and it becomes [ __ ] you
know I used to be that when I had all
the fancy cars I knew - Carla had him
down back I couldn't drive nothing now
you can either drive any model drive
people drive me out
you know I get nasty in these cars now
you know we get weak so I would say my
driver got disease new Veyron yeah yeah
I think I didn't know how to get start
the car hey no no excuse the fever the
beer on and the char on those are very
hard Kai's cars to figure out it friend
no nothing so what do I do
it is like ooh I can do nothing I would
be mad I'm [ __ ] low-tech grow deep in
low-tech dude so you never thought about
going back into like um you actually
know what well you never thought about
going like like I wanna coaching or
trying to do it that stuff like that
that's that's so complicated there's no
what kind of guy am I'm difficult
I'm hard I'm just starting to become a
good parent you know me I have no
patience and [ __ ] these guys got so it's
like being a shrink it like being a
mother a parent a psychiatrist you're so
many different name a teacher it's just
man and you think um listen you can't
believe some of the issues some of these
young kids have yeah you know I mean not
true yeah now that makes sense because I
have no patience either but at the same
time to hear this kids story they're
going through some [ __ ] and it just puts
you at this all right now you gotta take
care of it so I listen um I just found
that um my month my mother it's my
mother its current my mother has AIDS
and my girlfriend's pregnant I said hold
on what that's it that's that comes
through here yeah my mother and my
mother had the AIDS my girlfriend's
pregnant and I'm 16 years old
right okay yeah trying to figure out how
to connect with people and their
chlorination out I was just curious
about that my my next is this funny cuz
now I'm hi I'm trying to think of things
and go for it
so my last but well the only main thing
I thought about I know it sounds silly
I'm a movie buff i watch a lot of movies
[ __ ] around the whole thing did you
ever watch that HBO special they made
with you and Michael Jai White the the
no you watched it yeah why there's
Michael J it was like oh that was an HBO
types um when I got out of prison in 95
when I was in prison they made it so let
me ask you a question what did you think
about that you think it was somewhat
accurate the way it wasn't
yeah but the guy did have some
similarities to me he did a good job
yeah there's good no I mean like
remember the incident with where Michael
John Warner played your best friend oh
no Malcolm tomorrow warned ya played
your best friend in the movie I'm saying
movie yeah who was that dude in your
life Rory's my best you know I happy I
was uh training so much I didn't have no
friends I was in kasi I was training so
much for fort so much for 15 times in
one year so I don't have time to
socialize the people in 30 miles north
for me with Albany New York
and I was friends with his brother cuz
above the athlete but his brother got
married he lived his life and I guess
they didn't want me being involved I was
singling yeah so I started hanging out
with him we started hanging out became
close friends so did you really um he
was it was like manager yours is in the
one point or yes okay so remember that
in the movie there's a part where we all
walk in late to practice and in it the
coaches mad forgot who he worked under
cus he was mad and you like man [ __ ]
this did you really go in the ring and
hit them people and knock them dudes
that the the sparring partners out there
like nah [ __ ] this no thanks mr. Tyson
yeah they walked out there happy it was
like that knocking dudes out like that
one point foul what you want to do now I
was just curious if that was if that was
accurate because um when I was in
college and we played football I
remember my coach would always say
before the games what a custom model say
bad intentions he's like you need to go
out throw a bad [ __ ] intentions bad
intent and it was funny he always would
say that as a trip yeah bad heard punch
do him bad intention that's crazy man
I'm a train those are some of the bad
intentions then where do you think we
come from what do you mean who are you
who are you
what are we what's your purpose here
because my purpose here is to who you
can't know really who you came from
where you gonna go we think when you die
I think you think this is gonna really
go away you think there's no what's
happening I forget that body that by
this man what you feeling right now what
you thinking right now no one can get
you think that's gonna go away so this
is the crazy part you think that dies
what you think when no one no you don't
think that dies I add up for most of all
my life I was afraid of death I've been
afraid of it for all my life it [ __ ] me
up
in fact now if I think about it too deep
I think about like no matter what I do
like there's no certainties right but
death is certain right and by what you
do oh no okay
theft you another form of living true
true true so I thought about I said
listen I think about my kids down and
I'm so worried about how they're gonna
live and and I want them to be to have
the best life I don't want them to die
you know I'm just thinking of something
to be on some Peter Pan [ __ ] but I'm
like okay well in 2200 we ain't gonna be
here for sure who knows whatever and I
think about it but I've only had two
real best friends of my adult life like
after 25 years age I've had two best
friends in my life
one of them with my godfather and then I
was best man at his wedding for the
other one both then passed away both
them very successful one black one asian
asian guy weren't owned a
quarter-million-dollar cup at quarter
billion dollar company the black dude
owned a 700 million dollar company
called WorldStarHipHop right it's my bet
my best friends of my life and they both
passed away when they both passed away I
got weird with myself I said this can't
be it there's no way you know the
university about that money elite don't
worry about that we're take care of it
but come on come with me the more work
to do
yeah so I think about it like I think
like I know my mom is getting there
she's getting she's getting older I'm
just saying like damn man oh no you know
should I be around us that's kind of
crazy how you know now I'm kind of
taking care of her why I'm taking care
of her in a certain sense and I say you
know how do you have conversations this
can't be hit you know me so I'm taste
I'm crazy this is true story 100% true
my younger son is five years old right
now when Q passed away he was three
barely three like two and
three so when Q was around a lot
he doesn't murmur any of that so yeah I
doubt he knows the guys black but
there's a lot of black people that he'll
he sees she doesn't know that this guy's
really key would remember him right so
five months after Q died I don't believe
in ghosts I don't believe in none that
[ __ ] I'm just not I don't believe in a
lot of things you know I'm very
skeptical of a bunch of things but you
know I am spiritual to a certain set you
know to it to a certain extent and my
wife walked over to my son and goes hey
what are you doing and he goes oh mommy
I'm just playing and he goes while
you're talking who you playing with he
goes oh I'm playing with Q and my wife
stopped my wife believes in all the [ __ ]
I don't write when one stops guys know
my wife believed then she goes what did
you say because I'm playing with uncle Q
ankles where's uncle Q hat and our house
is in the area there a dining room
there's a corner of glass it's all glass
Keir all glass here and you could see
out into like a little forest area so my
wife goes where's Uncle Q at and he goes
right there mommy
it's right there and so she just freaked
out and calls me immediately
she's like a business what happened I
was like oh man you know whatever you
know who [ __ ] knows okay that night
were giving them a bath my wife has the
exact same earrings I made Q before he
died like then he had a long music we
was dead big diamond earrings exact
color exact same size even and he goes
hey mommy yeah the same earrings as q
she goes what are you talking about it
goes uncle q has the same earrings and
so I said all right hold on so I went
and I went through a bunch of pictures I
showed her picture of Baron Davis the
NBA player I was like who's this he goes
I don't know daddy how's it going who's
this and I don't know that he was
Lucifer right and then who's this goes
that's uncle Q he's never seen a picture
on the phone or anything I was like that
[ __ ] me up that Q's around watching
all my family and just like that just
think about this maybe sometimes q is
that bug too flying around the house and
squash him he's trying to tell you hey
man what's going on it's me and I killed
them right yeah I don't know man you
know um I want to believe that we go to
rest
and their little crazy yeah do you feel
like rest in them they'll take your body
away if we energy do you feel like raft
me not gonna rest not gonna let our body
needs rest but we don't need raft so
what do you so so okay so that's just
where I'm at I'm afraid of it's still
uncertain what do you feel like like are
you afraid of death
nah no way I used to be as well no way
okay so now when you think
uuuuu die as up your body dies right you
die what do you think happens then I
don't know I believe that we go to a
universe we go to a different universe
do you believe in heaven in hell
no way I used to build know what I
believe that one time I believe that um
we just died the energy died I believe
then I took I took this on ancient
medicine as ancient medicine drug
whatever you wanna call it call it told
the man I think that I died and I'd be
like definite definite enough part of
living dan I mean I'm sure you've had
friends pass away a parent somebody
whatever when when you feel how you feel
like has there anybody recently like
passed away my friend my friend mother
who I was in that day this morning
damn I'm sorry so yeah it's good though
I didn't I would be feeling bad - I
understand my wife of my mother lovely
mother i understanding that my
perception of it my perception of it
it's not from a sad perspective my
selfishness of their physical flesh is
what I miss their flesh is maybe to do
something for me that's why I was you
know I mean they could hug me they can
love me they can go to store think about
me food you know they can talk to me
when I need comments see all that stuff
is no longer around so when you pass
away do you think that you're gonna be
all see her again no no no so what the
hell do you think what means in another
form may be may be in another form
because it's when I took this drug and I
died I wasn't it was not it was just the
energy with no arms no legs [ __ ] it was
like oh [ __ ]
numbers feelings consciousness feeling
just feeling I'm feel like I'm
physically I'm I'm feeling physical pain
from the feeling then think I'm
the pain of everybody I have a hurt
imagine feeling the pain labor you ever
heard you offended you struck you you
assaulted whatever you got the worst
that's the worst punishment ever that's
terrible yes everything is every drug
away every liquor every soda every pop
every anything I've always killed
anything I've ever done to my life a
fill it again anything I ever done in
that is everything everything feeling
now you're gonna [ __ ] me up tonight when
I go to sleep I just how many hours of
sleep do you get tonight I don't get any
three hours the most yeah [ __ ] man then
I have to turn talking about get freaked
out being when it's too quiet around in
my head stop [ __ ] me about death and
[ __ ] that's all I used to be that's why
I think about other things but I thought
about it like in the last ten years I
get like four hours maybe five and it
just [ __ ] my I just don't get it cuz
people say oh you need sleep you know
that's why Robin Harris died in and out
of sleep Robin Harris had the disease
where you dropped oh sleep well that
disease called not ellipsis oh that's
what he was I didn't know that he would
come in the office I had an office in
California Backman even coming office
and my partner used to pay him cuz he
started he opened up the show for Robin
and I'm that Club what was the name of
it but anyway they opened that Club and
he's the coming weekend involved me
before sleeping office always in the
chair she wasn't just tired
no yeah I didn't know that [ __ ] man was
crazy if he started all the black
comedian him all the first start
everybody step Eddie Murphy everybody
else oh you know what man you got to
meet
Donnie Yen you did it man died again for
my man yeah me ask you question is is he
an actor's he actually kick kick some
ass he can kick the math too but he's
very dangerous hurt himself
then my surgeries lot of injuries yeah
dance crazy cuz when I saw that I was
like whoa I already love the series it
is awesome person yeah you met Jackie
Chan before right yeah yeah I got to
meet Jackie challenge thought about him
doing the stunts and [ __ ] doing honestly
I was just Jackie um Donnie and it's
Arthur
you know mrs. awesome he's not even
Chinese Chinese without Cisco so I think
Washington wavy Whitney from Donnie Yen
is an American I mean more Chinese about
things though why didn't he speak
English - very well
oh sure I know that very well we call
these awesome awesome [ __ ] guy he's
[ __ ] like us give me your meet us
Steven Seagal yeah at the movie Widow oh
he really knows Aikido right he's a real
bad one but that's what they say
oh I used to love watch this dude that
people talk about this there's a
folklore about you know like hey he
could put you down in one second as
amount of Aikido watching his videos
dude
he teaches cops down in New Orleans yes
this cop training so you don't know you
don't know that's why I went on 1,000
this could be interview gonna find out
if he really knows really did you find
out well he that we he never had the
fight things would be eating them lead
and show us it's still up in the air
what if he's legit I don't know if he's
legit yeah like this you have skills can
we put in the movies we [ __ ] up did he
[ __ ] up some people on the street he
fights with he has a show it's on like a
and E where he does cop he dismembered
my mum with cops he was supposed to be
in some altercation with Van Damme
against Van Damme like really backed up
I mean I met jean-claude Van Damme a
couple times man I do too small man yeah
he's way smaller than I thought he comes
in here no he does yes smokes okay yeah
that's good who who have you men by Dan
you smoke holy [ __ ] I don't know if I
forgive me for many people know I know I
can't imagine like even when you talk
about their smoke you know know when you
talk about Michael Jackson on on
Michaels thing you said you said he
didn't know you were uh I was so mad at
Mike even though he's passed away rest
in peace like I was so manly how to [ __ ]
you not know who Tyson is I know he was
[ __ ] with me
oh he was [ __ ] with you she's [ __ ]
with me yeah he knew who I was
oh man that's even worse listen I'm
right he's standing by the door waiting
for a car to come pick him up and
everybody his band played gave me a pub
the [ __ ] drumsticks the girl came in
kay buddy - my
all great men taking pictures of me
these are sitting waiting for the car to
pick them up I said well let me just go
over there the mic is when you say
something to him right and when I go up
to it I was gonna say you know what I
know you found and the [ __ ] I said okay
no ass I'm nobody's can say my fan did
you wanna hit a man like well you know I
I said [ __ ] I was all at all when he
said that was like [ __ ] okay cool but
afternoon that's that NASA [ __ ] Michael
Jackson you know he's talked to me in
third person when we meet like this yeah
he would talk to him well he knows that
he never did I was like okay listen
let's just keep it real to it who the
[ __ ] are we the [ __ ] [ __ ] what do you
expect [ __ ] on each other you're not
wrong Mike do we think we are we don't
even we don't have to but we don't have
no perception perception of what we
really are what we will be [ __ ] I
descend from become from monsters
barbarian people that eat each other
no you really read all those Alexander
great books huh yeah he's amazing
confused young man he was a drug addict
to an alcoholic that's why he walks will
for him was so father took the [ __ ] I
need I need
what drugs would he do Mike he do a bit
to anibus no he do hash I think he
brought her to the Afghanistan oh really
credible where was he wasn't it wasn't
he from Europe he's from Greece
Macedonia Macedonia so foul a seven-hour
ride so he one elephant no car Nick
listen there was cars back then no and
if you drove a car with obviously a hat
on you Alexander the Great gets a [ __ ]
get to authors and them boats and [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] when they travel didn't travel
hours was under the auspices they
traveled with a bunch of men 50,000 men
fix it up no it was a part like 50,000
men 60,000 women little kids dumb
drummers [ __ ] on your whole city a
city yet architects and everything
everybody
some men I'm [ __ ] them people that
bill should all of architects anybody we
all drop the party and everybody's
getting high drinking and it's just
everything we everything we go upon we
[ __ ] it up we eat it up part of our
country pre Rome he's before long before
Rome yeah damn did what'd he do pave the
way for Rome listen bill a hundred
percent Roman people thought he was a
god you never hold you never heard
anything about Roman people till I was
then they died at 336 BC then Rome came
out because they thought he was a god
that's all you heard was he it was he
getting [ __ ] was he getting [ __ ] or
no [ __ ] and [ __ ] he was [ __ ]
everything yeah what yeah Feli rolled
back then bro holy [ __ ] that was why I
was crazy
that's how do you feel about like how
like now that you don't like the United
Airlines trying to put like the the sub
category now or you know some saying are
you male female or are you ex like how
do you feel about the whole transgender
thing like people are saying like like
that [ __ ] is it trip to me I'm just
saying like you were going a certain way
man I know why I know I have the trip to
you because how old are you 40 51 46 46
because we're primitive that's why
that's why I were primitive we don't
understand what happened listen and
Roman era they will [ __ ] you nasty they
should have a tray in public they did it
in public it was open it wasn't no
behind closed door they did it right
walk up the street go to your school
going to your bakery they did it right
in the street everything and that's just
the Roman at Romans young Roman era was
young they say 950 BC son left nothing
right you know that's just the [ __ ]
yeah well I mean the transgender stuff
you know this before God because he's
young
well when you think about all of the
chemicals that we're comprised of you
know we're we come together in our
mother's womb and it's billions and
trillions of atoms and molecules that
make us up and there's all these fluids
and hormones and transmitters and all
kinds of [ __ ] going on in our brain so
some people when you come through the
portal maybe you come in and you get a
male body but your mind as a female mud
I can't believe that okay you have a
female wiring okay what I'm getting at
is this and then and then I hope this
doesn't come off as a and vice versa and
some and all the way in between as well
right you know but you know people say
like oh you're being whatever just you
know how Twitter people complain and
they say [ __ ] like oh man you know um
this person said something about black
people this person that my Asian people
cancel and all that cancel culture [ __ ]
just dude
[ __ ] calm down yeah I used to love
watch lists of the Richard Pryor [ __ ]
tapes and making fun of Asian people or
listen to Eddie Murphy and listen to
these comic I didn't I mean if you need
to proofread it what's that
Bruce Lee didn't like that I'm going
about Bruce Lee yeah yeah go see them
[ __ ] around with that ya know not a
little bit was what [ __ ] with Asian
making stereotyping yeah yeah used to
get much the chip on his food a little
bit he lost jobs because of it
but what I'm getting at is like now
people are so sensitive about certain
vision and I mean you sit then you don't
know like I don't know how to address
somebody you know I mean like oh hey Vic
onami Victoria I don't you know your
sister thing right we all make mistakes
we don't know sometimes what to do what
to say but some people do a victim you
know mean yes viciously they know it's
offensive and they do it anywhere yeah
no I actually we make mistakes at it you
know ignorance you know it's not our
fault
of course people know what they do it
and they do it ya know man it's a it's a
[ __ ] crazy time welcome to the future
yeah no it's [ __ ] no but my son has a
[ __ ] cell phone bro you know it's
like bugs me out that's crazy yeah
listen um Steve job must have been a
very
just in person he didn't want actual
information for know anyone actually
anybody how do I get here what time is
it anything somebody may ask somebody
with some direction they must add ISTA
my something so you made you get your
own directions and your phone a taxi
anybody [ __ ] you'll have to communicate
with nobody you have to care about their
feelings how to kick you only care about
the phone not a phone don't have any
feelings no yeah I think Steve Joss
smoke weed though little water acid
liked a lot of acid you know acid the
San Francisco thing man you know I live
this iris Cisco went well and I was in
cars have a fiscal the athlete's day and
I [ __ ] did acid out there you know
the mean and that was like a crazy thing
because it's good stuff
oh no I thought I had some [ __ ] crazy
times on it I you know how you got you
have a TV and let's say it goes one two
sixty-five volume you already know I'd
like eight you can't hear that TV at 21
and I know I have a little about it
here's could be in the studio being a DJ
but like a 25 you might be able to hear
a little bit I'm not quiet so imagine
when it's not like six and there's 60
settings at 60 levels of volume on TV I
was on acid and I could hear one you
know me like level one I will hear and
it was loud and I'm like [ __ ] this is
crazy I remember I was like uh you know
I was dunking a junior in high school
and I remember we saw this basketball
court outside in the Sun tensed district
in those regulation if anything he might
have been nine foot ten whatever and I
was like a man I was like [ __ ] I want to
go grab the rim right now that was
nothing just because we're in a ball and
I'm wearing an orange hoodie and a royal
blue like sweats I'm wearing like
yellows I look crazy and I jumped up and
I thought I jumped high as [ __ ] and my
teammate goes a bro you came about 50
inches away from the rim he's you case
so far away from touching that rim like
what the [ __ ] you tell me what the only
thing I do didn't know is you don't want
to drive on asset that's like the last
thing tell me if you learn a lot what
makes you happy I see that fancy cars
nah [ __ ] all that [ __ ] on me nothing
makes you happy what really makes me
happy is hearing my kids laugh when I
hear my daughter my her cry it just my
whole thing's like rock man when I hear
my kids laugh and they're having a good
and it combines a daddy like you have a
[ __ ] up day in traffic for two hours
and I'm mad about being in traffic which
is first world problems and then I'm mad
that someone [ __ ] up and didn't get a
delivery right and then I'm mad about
somebody else because they told somebody
some secret information about our
company and I get home like daddy what
do you think he kids want to do you know
I don't know man I think my son my
oldest holiday the oldest one is six
he's almost seven you know but I think
he wants to be in something like marine
biology wants to be like a he wants do
something with water he's a water boy
loves swimming love sharks
he can name every specie of shark since
four years old he can name every species
start he corrected somebody out of
aquariums I love that and people like
the guy was like no no no and I was like
I was like are you sure you guys I'm
positive and like my son is very very
smart spoke late was very smart my
middle son he's just like me he's the
splitting image exact like me he is
gonna be a [ __ ] lady killer he's
gonna get a lot of trouble he's gonna
[ __ ] around anything I lost my daughter
I can't tell you it's too young but
she's trying to you know kind of be
spoiled that's what makes me happy my
seeing my kids good
that makes me happy more anything I know
it sounds terrible when my wife is good
to it my everything is going me and my
wife man my shoulders are like [ __ ] I
can chill yeah you know breathe but
because I travel so much I was on 60
flights last year I've been on 33 this
year 34 this year and it's like [ __ ] you
know like and they're wondering why I'm
like I'm trying to do this [ __ ] because
I don't want to work in a few more years
I wanted to sit back be like oh you're
gonna get bored no I won't because my
kids would keep me keep me occupied I'm
good that's what I'm gonna do
that's still man I feel like I was
punished worth to two so I want my son's
to be jewelers I don't want to be in
music you know they want to whatever I
just wanted to be I wanted to listen I'm
a young boy coming up in the world the
most some of the most attractive things
the world has to offer and this to the
world is entertainment injury and that's
was my father doing I'm not gonna do
that
[ __ ] man yeah sure
I just he's such a [ __ ] character like
I just I watched
why did you don't want me that because
you know what I'm dealing with those
kind of personality yeah man I just want
to do something
like I don't know man it was just it's
it's a all the scumbags I'm minute I
can't imagine how scumbags you've been
in your life but I I met so I worry
about my favorite older son - and listen
um
I see me start to hang out with these
guys that I know that I used to know
they'd been ex-mafia these guys it's
just weird that um they follows that
[ __ ] in there I say must be something to
do with me that's why you think that my
instinct inside they think I'm a tough
guy if he wants to be a tough guy out
there I know these kind of guys you know
I think this is instinctively that's
what do you think but like how old your
daughter you said my son how did your
daughter then have a ten-year-old and
then how did you have one that's have my
oldest one is 28 okay besides old do you
have one that's like like between 18 and
20 16 year old okay 16 year old if she
wants to go on a date and a guy meets
you aren't they scared
yeah I tell them that Phil listen come
here man well you owe me this all I'm
saying to you whatever you do to my do
it I'm gonna do to you so make sure
there's no tongue kiss okay yeah ma'am
Howard enough with the girl I lost my
virginity when I was 12 you know saying
I was out I was a crazy kid man that's
that's [ __ ] up like yeah if I came to
someone's well I can't even scare them
now they're you know Nate you can't
scare people you're not scaring is
supposed to happen crazy isn't it weird
that listen
explain this why do we need a mate
why don't we die without of me why we
have so many good why did we decide to
get married hey I don't wanna do it no
more what about it cuz it's one girl why
don't we decide to do that is why does
it it's nothing I don't think it's
something um how I think it's not from a
philosophical perspective it's not
something you just say I think it's
meant from God has meant from nature
something why do we do that why at the
end of our life somebody
did they fool around all their life and
in their life they decide to settle down
with somebody why do they do that I feel
like it's for well me person I grew up
in a broken home yeah I'd like to have
more maybe more to your level not to be
involved somebody who you used to not
have true but but I always I always
yearned for having a happy household you
know I mean like one thing now we don't
do that we did it when I was a little
kid we did and then it fell apart but my
to my kids I oh this kid has a lot of
allergies he has a lot of health issues
and they have a strict diet and they eat
dinner really early what I want to do
now when my daughter gets a little older
I want us all to eat dinner at the same
time eat at the same table at least I
mean I dinner if we could do breakfast
that'd be great but everyone's on
different schedules it's a different
different day we live in but ma'am I'm
so [ __ ] high right now
no I'm saying uh it was a sense of
security I don't want to be honest I've
heard I've read stories about people
dying because they were lonely and like
certain things and I don't have a lot of
friends you know I mean I have a ton of
acquaintances but I have very few
friends in my life like real friends I
don't have a lot I'm a hard person to be
around I guess but I love the fact that
when I come home my wife is home the
family's home boom it's like you know
she's she has a good environment it's
it's good energy in the house a good
vibe you know and and I love to see my
kid learn something about something
every day it's beautiful no and that's
that's that's for me I want to settle
down and have that life do you know and
and I see some of my boys where 50 years
old late 40s or their 40s and they're
still in the club trying to [ __ ] young
girls and I'm like but what are you
doing you're 60 or 70 goes out [ __ ]
I'll kill myself I want to [ __ ] be
around I'm 60 or 70 and I'm like all you
trip yeah what happens when you're 60
like yeah I want to live but I said I
was gonna kill myself yes I said that
when I was in my 20s
I'm nothing live I'll kill mother I
won't wanted one I didn't want to get
old and stuff I am so happy I didn't do
that right no because what is old it's
when you can no longer function I guess
right we basing them on being oh we're
gonna be mistaking after 50 was old
fifties not oh yeah I know yours
craziest 50s not old and it [ __ ]
because I'm close to 15 it just my said
my sisters if you think you still think
the same trust me
yeah oh you think kids looking out for
you still think the same so damn man cuz
I'm gonna no more
I met Muhammad Ali like 25 years ago
maybe or 30 years ago I met Muhammad Ali
and he was like kind of in like he was
kind of like you know like he was it was
taking him 20 minutes skin and paper
towels had a the palm restaurant on
Santa Monica Boulevard he was trying to
get a paper towel out of the sink and he
was the bathroom I said me and him a
small bathroom smaller than this and I
was like so I got this [ __ ] I got gave
Torrance it here you go champ
right and one time he moved full fashion
with me but [ __ ] his hands can't
believe that he moved too [ __ ] fast
you can see his hand now he can't move
at all we said ma you saw Ali box I've
seen him on television okay
oh you know film right Matt be the fatty
missing credit be gosh she the math of
God no way people don't know that cuz
he's such a smooth guy movie think of
him with the liens he's big 64 220
pounds yeah he was a big guy it was that
fast [ __ ] lightning fast don't man damn
man
do you do you don't train it alright no
I work out
keeping soup treadmill yeah you know
when John Singleton passed it [ __ ] me
up cuz he was relatively young like 51
isn't like John you John that's not saw
me then like Venice Beach somwhere area
from where we were he was living in his
boat he was with Michael Rapaport like a
month ago
yeah and they he went to go visit my
crap but you're a stand-up comedy act
and they talked you know I saw him like
a year or so ago I saw him at Whole
Foods and I just like yo man that's
young you know so I'm like I didn't know
anything was wrong with him you don't
know nothing's wrong with people get
something we don't know anything people
keep oh you don't ask you that - do you
really think that there's just it's it's
even if you keep yourself healthy you
keep yourself decent you know you're
good everything else you think that that
there there's everyone has their own
time and no matter what you do how good
you keep your health everything
it could just take it take you out yeah
listen let's let's talk about that
I believe anybody has their own time
right but I believe preparing for your
time is getting in the best shape
possible you could be you know I mean
that's you just let your stuff waste
away yeah you know you stay healthy and
have good love for yourself no that's
good to say that man I'm in the worst
shape of my life right now I've never
been physically I'm sorry physically I'm
gonna work shaking my life and my
bounce-back game ain't like it used to
be do you know no start start start
walking the beat you start with two more
one more than two mile a treadmill yeah
I've been in different the bush which is
great I've been in different I'm trying
to go a little yeah I trying to go
trying to go low-carb that's when we get
caught up in the world we gorged what's
that what's the most you ever weighed on
400 pounds 400 yeah I'm an animal what
I'm doing my cocaine wanna come off my
cocaine I will eat the whole [ __ ]
with that Dairy Queen that's my face
very good very clean I'm going in I
order like I'm [ __ ] you know comes in
the box 24 in the box
yeah 24 the old net and before I would
get my [ __ ] blimpy my cookie oh yeah
yeah big-time eat that and then right
before that I take two I open up my box
of ice cream and I think my two [ __ ]
sticks out you start eating my ice cream
and stuff then throw that away the
monster
cocaine I we just go for and what's the
leanest you've been as an adult and then
though around to 16 what you fought at
2:16 right yeah okay yeah so [ __ ] you
know what I realized man and I realized
this after I honest I haven't done coke
in horrible it's been almost you know
it's been 21 years since I did coke and
I'ma tell you okay never want to do it
again don't care - don't want to I found
some dudes said this I was at Hollywood
party
like Johnny Depp's houses some [ __ ] and
this dude goes a man you know a coke is
coke is a drug is a drug with a height
it doesn't exist
mm and when he said that it [ __ ] my
whole life because I realized I felt
like I was a [ __ ] you know I'll be
in an ass or whatever and I was up but I
really wasn't like if there really were
I was chasing a high it didn't exist out
really I was that made so much sense to
me that lighter that's the truth like I
see people do it now I'm like nah man
I'm cool man like oh why you'd be like
bro man shut the [ __ ] up bro I'm good I
go ahead do your little your little [ __ ]
yeah but it just didn't excite me like
we'd always excited you I'll tell you
things that that excite like drinking
lean I was at it do you know the me no
tell me about the have that work wait on
you it does for sure yes so so I was
addicted to this [ __ ] and yeah coding so
at the time it was in 2005 to 2009 it
was like a 3200 month a month habit
today they don't exist anymore right
there other ones but it's not the same
these two companies our farm line ox
office they're activist is one of the
biggest pharmaceutical companies in the
world so they created this this thing
that tasted delicious and you would just
get so [ __ ] up it was a euphoric high
and you would just be leaning like y'all
I'm good you could have sex you do it
the [ __ ] you want you go to sleep
forever you just you just [ __ ] lean
and really to sleep forever don't worry
girl yeah that too
so a ball of that now is like 10 grand
so I'd have it I I'd have literally
let's see I'd have a like 320 thousand a
month habit if that was the case you
know I mean when I got it was nothing
but they don't exist anymore so people
are doing then people were going because
it's purple
people are getting great dimetapp
putting a syringe in the grapeshot tap
and poke you a hole at the bottom of it
and [ __ ] taking it out you know I'm
saying so mixing it diluting it but that
was a high that loves so much that I
realized one your livers about to
[ __ ] go because you [ __ ] alt LXE
uh
SLC whatever t levels will go up my
liver was enlarged it was pushing my
chest out I gained the Ginga weight I
was getting [ __ ] up so that was like
something I loved I just miss everything
else is like I remember when I have my
stomach surgery they gave me propofol
and then he gave me morphine and I got
shot before too so I'm
got morphine and I got shot not being
robbed I was stopping a domestic
violence thing and I've never ever
jumped in front of and jump you motherf
anothing comes in between dick and [ __ ]
nothing nothing as soon as you try to
man but going on I'm in the world's
closer than they can [ __ ] want to get
together yeah
ain't no hug this so you know IIIi got
morphine when I got a nose like I
literally within not even two minutes of
this IV I'm in pain I'm in [ __ ] pain
my back is like on fire and I remember
he gave me the morphine with the IV and
I was like whoa no while I'm on I was
cool but yeah no I mean I love morphine
but they just I just was told by where
the [ __ ] was I I was a doctor's office
somewhere they just say ketamine is
legal now yeah my friends used to do
that [ __ ]
knock I think they're dead I think
they're [ __ ] dead
oh [ __ ] no yeah it's 8 acad is strong
but just handed I forgot who said it
doing therapy ketamine treatment
yeah ketamine treatment zero but there's
ketamine regardless I'm saying they're
doing something with it for like PTSD -
III did it doses that gives me tell me
about that [ __ ] and I was in a [ __ ] I
was in a nightclub in New York City I'm
like I told y'all not religious my dad
was a minister and it forced me to go to
church for 17 year whatever how many
years well I turned 18 i man [ __ ] this
church [ __ ] everything about this [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] cuz I hate this [ __ ] right
I said [ __ ] this [ __ ] ass [ __ ] I
remember I was on K I was like 28 years
old I'm in New York City nightclub and
my boy goes you know when you see a loan
if you're doing coke but you see a line
of coke or you know a bump you're like I
cool
ya know cool ain't no [ __ ] yeah hey you
got a fight don't let me see why you
can't kill me you gotta like put tiny
little bits
as a message okay Jessup yeah sure boy
goes oh [ __ ] bro that's Special K no
[ __ ] is Special K man okay that's his
name that the coke and he was like no
bro
huh then 30 minutes 45 minutes later
Evan my face is on the ground in a
nightclub Bros packed as a [ __ ]
Winningham club got a 4:00 a.m. there
you know [ __ ] pops two three four yeah
my face my nose is touched the ground on
face forward as one doing a flat push-up
and I'm sitting there I said Jesus
seventy-five hundred thousand times
right oh and my boy goes hey you suck in
what's called a k-hole yeah like I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm stuck
don't you ever let me do that [ __ ] again
[ __ ] I was stuck in a chaos on
the floor flight [ __ ] 30 minutes guys
like eight of clubs on the cost I don't
give a [ __ ] what the club going to do
bro oh no buddy yeah no one can move you
you're done and obviously people were
hitting my arms were people stepping on
it didn't matter I couldn't feel none of
that [ __ ] it was like man what is this
[ __ ] bro oh god I'm sorry man
no no no it's all good toad the toad the
toad the Sonoran Desert Toad also known
as bufo alvarius its venom is collected
for this molecule called five Meo DMT
you ever done DMT no I am tea is a
psychedelic and the Oh genic compound
that we produce it in our bodies I've
read some recent studies I used to say
that we produce it in our pine Neil
gland but that's not actually nobody
actually knows if that's true or not you
get two hits of DMT in your life once
when you come into being in your
mother's womb and then once on your
deathbed so they say it's the portal of
the soul and so this toad it has this in
its venom
and they collect it and you can vaporize
it and it cures people of addiction and
depression and the fear of death and you
experience God you go to the source and
you see your life flash drives you go
death is DMT illegal or is it is it over
the economy I think it's illegal
you can do it ceremonially you can go to
like Brazil or and do ayahuasca that's
where DMT is that's like so as a toad
okay it's the top of the pyramid oh [ __ ]
so the toad they call it the god
molecule under that DMT is the spirit
molecule yeah I did that too you did the
toad free DMT that was fun had a ball
with the empty the toad is serious
we're just where'd you first try the toe
that I tried to close area in Mexico
somewhere
but listen Wrangler shaman what a
showman listen when I did this thing
right that's why I did all kinds of
drugs before imma do this [ __ ] this is
no no yeah I'm on cocaine right now a
leash it hurt me so I'll do this [ __ ]
and I said oh [ __ ] I'm dead I [ __ ] I
was dead I just [ __ ] I was dead I
couldn't feel my body my body was going
nothing existed no more and it was gone
neither [ __ ] it's like I said I did 250
milligrams like it's like it's like
crystallized yes trip I let you smoking
in the joint one day oh you'd like to
yeah let me take it fun so you use
lighter then use less yes okay I'm like
a V and how long is a hot glass 20
minutes what yeah come on man listen
listen
that's what hey listen time in your mind
when she do the drug right if some it's
all there's no time you in the middle of
time and space nothing exists you don't
know what time is anyway comes out 20
minutes you'd survive if it lasts more
than 20 minutes my dear
might get a heart attack so your
consciousness the way you perceive the
world the the lens that you project and
you experience everything in is separate
from your God kind of everything every
everything could you know is expose
everyone knows it but it's at title
everything everything that you know what
nobody knows exposed everybody know you
got the feel of everybody knowing your
business everything your consciousness
is tied to your physical you can imagine
by your ego have you tried it I've done
DMT I haven't done the toad I haven't
been called to the toad but you know oh
you can't just go do it it's it's some
special [ __ ] like you have no time you
want you can go seek it out and you
could do it when you're not gonna do it
when you did DMT yeah
it was it no that was like an eight-hour
trip oh I did the empty I did the won't
you small okay that's that's like 15
minutes - yeah yeah as long as you're
doing it less does it give it like a
it's like a coke hyper higher as a
college is for your connection the toad
is like you know the other different
domain planet no more listen you don't
see your body
you only got feelings you don't seem
there's nobody just to this day the only
drug I've never done in my life is
heroin is because I thought I'd like it
too much and I was like going up what
I'm saying it's the only thing I've
never done I've done everything else
yeah now I've never done DMT and [ __ ]
and total that's a totally different
natural but you don't think everything's
happened to you you think that you think
you know should you seen [ __ ] you've
been over the world you seen things you
you've seen the world right yeah well
really a [ __ ] really can't tell
you [ __ ] really I mean listen tell us
you really for the most part I might be
true out the election we get the toad
you won I don't know [ __ ] oh wow I need
that oh yes you do trust me I did - I
needed to talk I thought I knew [ __ ] of
the bad mostly been seen where I didn't
[ __ ] what I've been a drink when I've
been a bin who I've been with and then
and then I did the total find that I'm
nothing I've never seen anything never
be anybody now let me ask you a question
we were just sitting in a room or were
you like were you out and I was laying
now they have the lady that who you move
around you might [ __ ] hurt yourself
so you get to lay down on a bed on the
floor and then cost us talking to you so
some people scream everybody is
different everybody's [ __ ] Amedeo he
said it [ __ ] me up the worst every
secret about you ever oh man you know I
listen and you think and didn't this is
why I know what happened you got all
that said oh god please I don't even
know
oh no once you stop nobody gets a [ __ ]
nobody's wrong the way he's right
there's no Lord there's no space there's
no time everything that's we running
down the physical world is a [ __ ] lie
20 minutes bro that's like no know what
it's like in 20 minutes it's like
fifteen hundred fifteen fifteen hundred
years of experience and [ __ ] 20
minutes
man that fast let's go I couldn't
imagine it's going so fast
Oh looking at you Wow sad I'm [ __ ] up
right now I'm like wow that's crazy
we should get some lunch I'm down lunch
is good guys hey brother do you want
anybody to know how to find you mom
anything new you're going on where can
they check out the VVS pens yeah yeah
yeah but you should do that before you
think you should make something that
should be like listen the [ __ ] the
Bob Oilers [ __ ] whatever this is your
emblem and everybody should have this is
you think you down you in the hood you
wouldn't the street you shared this
anybody know you down if you have one of
these okay yeah I have one of those pens
you know yeah for sure
that's something I'm a death-row had
they they have people take understand we
had that you too cool no matter you
stole one of you bought 111 yeah that's
row emblem you were the man for sure um
I mean it's pretty easy you know on any
kind of social media been ballers my
actual name I think I'm more active on
the stories and I'm on the posts I'm a
little weird now cuz I think I exposed a
little too much of my personal life and
I remember people know like so now you
might not say no necessarily know what
I'm doing but you know I'm a dad
you
when you know that make jewelry you know
that I want a cannabis brand but ya know
Ben baller at Ben baller at anywhere on
social um and yeah my VVS pens company
is order VVS calm order VVS and then uh
VVS pens on instagram yeah man we just
I'm out here doing this and I cannot get
down with some nonprofits here and there
but I'd do something more personal so
that have been going through funnels and
channels of people I'll just pick out
random people like a family that because
I think about how expensive is go to a
Laker game and I heard this comedian
talk about all back in the day I go to
the Knicks game
I'll go get some beer I'll do this this
and this and it cost him like $17 for
the whole night I'm like you [ __ ]
kidding me like I go to the movies my
wife it's [ __ ] 250 years you know
yeah and it's like going to a Laker game
and I'm talking about sitting in the
middle I talk about blond those beads
and nowhere near the front levels you
know she's gonna cost a family of course
and the costume you know I'm saying
maybe $2,000 whatever it is so sponsor
some families I'd like to do if that's
like little small things I could do that
that's true yeah you know and and I just
like traveling because when I see how
other cultures live I'll see how that
goes
man that's why I can become more obvious
peak obviously become worldly and I like
to see how they how they live how they
eat in their country I just like to
really soak up a lot of the knowledge of
the world it gives me a better have you
noticed this when you go to certain
parts of the world people have nothing
but they're happy yeah have you seen
that in the Y yeah
because they don't expect anything we we
expect everything yeah you know we
expect these sumo things are we having a
good time so but if I don't get my
million I would call [ __ ] y'all guys
[ __ ] no you know what that's terrible
cuz because Phil Jackson in his book he
said never have any expectations you
never be disappointed and I say man yeah
but [ __ ] that I demand more out of life
you know I feel like I put a lot of work
and I should get this done and some
people don't speak up like you said
they're just they're happy and they're
content and I wish I was that sometimes
I think about it like my boy who from my
hood who works at Trader Joe's generally
he's a pretty happy guy
you know I'm sure he wants more here and
there but he's cool like he's content
cool he has no extra stress me my job
don't stop at 6:00 p.m. I mean I'm
saying that [ __ ] goes to [ __ ] 1 a.m.
4 a.m. 300 people hit me up from from
Africa and [ __ ] Australia all over
the world all there
were [ __ ] up but you know people
there.just and it's like damn as much as
I don't like the talk I do a lot of
talking on on interviews and things and
like I mean listen if you're watching
this podcast and and you run social
media or relations for a college or high
school and you want me to come down and
speak bop you know being an entrepreneur
getting out of the hood let me know I'll
do it for free you know I mean if it's
localness you know but but I've been
speaking at schools and talk about kids
know cuz they're like you know I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do it life
and somebody's gonna listen
somebody's gonna become one of the
greatest [ __ ] jury makers in this gene
absolutely that's what happened that's
the day they had to see somebody first
yep yeah you know that's why I said you
have to have to see you first once they
see you they can achieve thank you bro
thank you very much I'm through the man
very much
god bless much migrated up yeah awesome
man take us out big brother
all right y'all thank you for watching
this episode of hot boxing I'm Evan
Britton and I'm Mike Tyson and I'm Ben
baller be sure to subscribe to hot
boxing with Mike Tyson check us out on
iTunes as well until next time you know
we're out of here
[Music]